[Musique]
soir voir pour savourer chez les
intérêts qui s'appelle singer view nous
sommes en direct est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succinctement
succinctement alors je m'appelle bruno
gaccio je suis né le 14 décembre 1958 à
saint-etienne dans la loire
père immigré italien
mr papetière ouvrière papetière j'ai
grandi dans une cité industrielle de
saint-etienne au fond 6 de la rue de la
richelandière saint-etienne si on a qui
regarde ça leur fera plaisir
j'ai quitté l'école à 15 ans et demi je
suis venu à paris à 18 ans et depuis je
gagne ma vie en écrivant comme auteur
vous avez fait un peu de télé vous avez
été co auteur des guignols de l'info
aujourd'hui on va parler de médias a est
la question qui est un peu provoc c'est
est ce que les médias sont pas devenus
les nouveaux guignols de l'info
les fâchés par on était marrant il me
semble qu aux guignols on était marrant
et pour être tout à fait honnête je
regarde très peu la télévision très très
peu les médias j'ai arrêté de regarder
les chaînes d'info parce que ça me
rendait malade
mais je comprends le processus qui a
mené à ça il ya un processus qui est
assez simple et financier c'est que les
guignols coûtait à la grande époque des
guignols à peu près 18 millions d'euros
par an pour fabriquer dix minutes de
télévision quotidiennes
aujourd'hui n'importe quel débat avec un
animateur et 4 abrutis quatre personnes
autour d'une table qui s'engueulent ça
remplit une heure pour une somme
dérisoire et ils se sont aperçus les
dirigeants de chaînes que finalement si
on donnait ça aux gens il aimait aussi
alors que les guignols c'était des
auteurs des manipulateurs des
décorateurs des imitateurs des
costumières des maquilleuses toute une
une armada de techniques le tout sur
trois équipes une qui occupait le direct
une qui préparait un tournage est une
qui était en post prod
donc tout ça était
une immense machine
qui dont les grands moments faisait 300
fiches de paye pour moi
donc aujourd'hui dans un média personne
n'investira là dessus plus personne ne
le ferais
c'est dommage ou c'est pas dommage en
sais rien mais en tout cas je retrouve
pas aujourd'hui dans les médias
quelque chose qui ressemble aux guignols
c'est à dire
quelque chose d'ironique de réfléchi
de décrit de travailler
pour un résultat qui est d'abord de
faire rire si on y arrive
et si on n'y arrive pas
au moins de ne pas avoir honte quand on
a fini on regarde l'émission on se dit
c'était pas très drôle aujourd'hui mais
on n'a pas honte ce qu'on a raconté
était pas honteux
là on va vous faire un petit compliment
ouais j'adore ton pendant de nos jeunes
années vous avez un petit peu
affûté notre esprit critique merci
surtout dans la façon de comprendre et
d'analyser la dialectique médiatique et
surtout la propagande de guerre
on va prendre une expression qui est
très cher pour certains qui est la
guerre chirurgicale
que vous aimez vous avez mis brillamment
en scène avec le commandant stallone
sylvestre
est ce que est ce que ce travail de
décortication de la parole médiatique de
la parole politique n'est plus fait on
vise à part chez quelques-uns comme un
crime et où d'autre
n'est plus fait
ça laisse le terrain propice à toutes
les styles de propagande
alors il est fait toujours ce travail de
décryptage il est fait par beaucoup de
beaucoup de médias dont vous d'une
certaine façon
plutôt très bien
j'en regarde plein en faisant du sport
et je trouve ça beaucoup mieux que de
regarder
ou d'écouter de la musique j'écoute de
la musique par ailleurs mais là en
faisant du sport j'aime bien vous
écouter
le dernier que j'ai écouté ses
genoux c'est un lait de quoi ça parle
d'économie c'était avec nijdam g en 15
voilà c'était très très intéressant mais
quand on leur demande si ça va
s'effondrer ils répondent jamais ils
disent moi j'ai plutôt tendance à penser
que oui juste qu'il raconte mais ils
répondent pas donc ce travail sur les
médias il est fait mais il n'est pas
fait de façon extrêmement populaire
les guignols c'était pour moi
peut-être parce que c'est vieux
maintenant mais je crois que c'était une
émission parfaite parce qu'elle mettait
en scène
toutes les caricatures possible une
caricature du cadre info jt une
caricature physique avec une marionnette
une caricature vocal avec une imitation
une caricature de caractère que les
auteurs imputés à des personnages est
une caricature de gestuelle que les
manipulateurs réussissait à rendre en
observant la la marionnette en viande on
appelait les vrais des marionnettes en
viande et tout ça évidemment coûtait de
l'argent mais était devenu très
populaire donc 7
cette façon de rire et de décrypter de
façon populaire
devait en agacer plus d'un parce que
c'était
trois millions trois millions et demi de
personnes à la grande époque qui
regardaient maintenant une émission sur
n'importe quelle chaîne ii
d'infos les regards des passants mille
personnes maximum ses cent mille 80
cents mille personnes pour moi ça
intéresse personne
mais ce truc populaire devait gêner un
moment fait le fait d'en durcir le
l'esprit critique des auditeurs ont leur
expliquant que la guerre chirurgicale
c'est un effet de manche de propagande
de guerre qu'il faut la rendre dans
keable que les images soient jodie alors
que la guérilla rien de plus horrible
que la guerre mais c'était à l'époque de
la guerre de la première guerre du golfe
en moi j'étais pas encore aux guignols
suis arrivé juste après la première
guerre du golfe il ya la 5 je crois
qu'il ya guillaume durand qui présentait
le journal de la cinq et qui regardait
c'est génial regardez ça et on voyait
pas céder des missiles de des tirs de
bombes partout et c'était très beau
parce que c'était filmer avec des
caméras thermiques et on voyait du vert
du rouge infrarouge offre rouge et on
voyait des légendes grasset c'est
magnifique la guerre sept devaient
d'ailleurs pas de l'infrarouge boudin de
l'amplification luminescence hommage
était verte c'est ça je sais que je suis
incapable de le dire mais les gens
trouvaient ça beau et on a rendu la
guerre acceptable en disant ce sont des
frappes chirurgicales et chirurgicales
c'est normalement la chirurgie c'est
fait pour soigner c'est l'art vise un
endroit on s'y chirurgicale bon c'était
un peu la douche est quand même en été
sa rose est un peu large quand même mais
le fait de dire que c'était chirurgicale
ça permettait de vendre d'abord du
matériel militaire très pointu on envoie
un missile il arrive exactement au bon
endroit ne vous inquiétez de rien sauf
que quand on regarde les statistiques
les dernières guerres tu 90% de civils
les militaires ils sont plus touchés les
militaires ils sont avec un joystick il
on voit un drone son petit bout flétrie
bon j'ai fini mon maintien à toi raymond
lemay qui vient avant et
cette façon de ramener du sang
dans la guerre c'était le boulot des
eagles et aidera mais aussi une
géopolitique à la serpette qui était le
monde est partagé en trois il ya nous
les cocos les
et c'était assez une vision
juste de ce que les états unis pensent
du monde il ya eu les cocos du
les cocos et son parti on est tous
devenus du prod et cette
vision là
de façon drôle et populaire propager
ça évite à une une partie des gens qui
nous regardent est de croire ce qu'on
leur dit absolument alors qu'aujourd'hui
où est le contre pouvoir rigolo il ya
rien qui désamorce plus que l'humour et
ça c'est rien de plus urgent aussi deux
de plus dangereux que l'humour ah ben
c'est
ouais il ya un dessin de réserve qui
doit dater des années 70 où il ya une
une guerre qui commence enfin kiev censé
commencer et il ya un type qui rit aux
éclats il dit mais non on va pas se
battre pour eux iri et riri fini par
mourir le peuple se soulève en disant
c'est notre premier martyr allons à la
guerre
tac le mec c'est tellement mari qu'il en
est mort mais si tout le monde c'était
marie aurait jamais eu une guerre la
communauté qui aurait qui sont en train
de faire un affreux jojo qui est en
train de me faire remonter une carte
capture d'écran de monsieur sylvestre
avec nous les collines où les niakoués
les bouillouses il plaidé oui après oui
ça a bougé un peu après
après on a égard j'ai un peu
ils les ont encore j'adore
la question de cette information traiter
d'une façon différente alors que ce soit
avec humour ou que ce soit avec un autre
regard c'est ce qui manque dans notre
démocratie se réveille des médias
en termes critique face à la parole
donnée la parole la parole immanente du
gouvernement où la parole immanente de
certains c'est cette indépendance
médiatique qui nous manque c'est pour ça
que c'est devenu des guignols parce
qu'ils sont ma situation une démocratie
qui a peur de sa caricature elle souffre
elle est malade normalement la
démocratie n a pas peur la république
elle n'a pas peur les solides elle sait
ce qu'elle veut et c'est ce qu'elle ne
veut pas et elle le dit et tout se passe
bien quand on commence à avoir peur de
la caricature alors c'est qu'on va mal
c'est qu'on est en train de cacher des
choses ou c'est qu'on n'est pas solide
sur ses bases
pendant des années on nous a laissés
faire mais les guignols c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est
on arrivé de façon fortuite en fait
je crois qu'ils nous ont pas vu arriver
ils ont commencé à faire des petites
marionnettes ont disons assez rigolo et
puis
jean françois halin et benoît delépine
qui étaient les deux piliers renom
françois rollin a travaillé aux guignols
aussi venait de partir il y avait jean
marie gourio qui travaillait il était
parti aussi et eux ils ont pouvait plus
été rincé ils m'ont demandé parce que je
les connaissais ni tu venir travailler
avec nous ouais on va voir et moi en
arrivant j'ai dit mais quel outil
extraordinaire c'est un outil fabuleux
si on réussit à rendre populaire non
caricature les hommes politiques
dans ce qu'ils essaient de cacher parce
que on ne s'est jamais attaqué
et appuyer que sur l'image médiatique
des hommes politiques ce qu'il voulait
bien nous donner à voir mais pourquoi
vous voulez nous donner à voir cette
chose et pas telle autre pourquoi à ce
moment précis pourquoi par tel canal
pourquoi aujourd'hui et pas demain et
pas hier et tout c'est toute cette
réflexion là je me suis dit ça un outil
fabuleux on peut y faire du théâtre ça
va un castelet les gens qui jouent et on
peut y faire du cinéma on enregistrait
des sketches une fois par semaine
on peut y faire de l'éditorial
on peut donner un avis
on peut y faire de la politique
et force est de constater qu'on s'est
bien planté parce que on a fait élire
chirac et sarkozy est passé quand même
donc au bout du compte on servait pas à
grand chose mais
on nous a vraiment laissé faire ce qu'on
voulait pratiquement toujours
le pratiquement et
est important le pratiquement passé
quand et sur coup mais j'ai déjà raconté
ça donc c'est moins intéressant mais je
les raconte et lescure pierre lescure
qui était le président de canal+ en
1997 le bouton annoncée passera ça ça le
faisait marais salants ça ça allait tout
seul
nous a dit en 97 quand chirac a dissous
l'assemblée nationale
il nous a dit vous a convoqué dans son
bureau et il nous a dit voilà vous
pouvez pas ignorer que vous avez fait
tout les cover il aime bien parler
anglais pendant cette période de 95 et
que vous avez au moins eu une influence
sur un certain pourcentage des votants
pour chirac si financé par les russes
c'est ça alors non à l'époque on était
deux on est et balladuriens pour chirac
puis s'est rendu compte que pas tout à
fait excellent et des et balladur vous
pensais qu'on était chirac 1 alors que
nous on était de gauche on ne voulait
pas de ces deux époux
et donc il nous a dit comme vous avez eu
une influence on va arrêter les guignols
pour les législatives qui arrivent
et je lui ai dit d'accord on arrête les
guignols
m'a regardé et m'a dit
c'est youtube a pas plus que ça en fait
j balle on arrête les guignols qui vient
de le dire on arrête les guignols lions
pendant quinze jours j on arrête les
gagner parce que les clients n'ont
d'intérêt que dans un moment tendu et la
gloire une élection il va y avoir plein
de choses à dire et tu nous interdit de
le dire à ce moment là ça marche pas
donc là à partir de là il ya une heure
et demie de discussions à peu près
et on est arrivé à la conclusion
vous parlez de politique si vous voulez
mais je ne veux pas voir un personnage
politique parce que quoi qu'il arrive
vous allez en montrer un plus que
l'autre et il va finir plus sympathique
que l'autre et ça vous allait influencer
une élection jeudi deal on parle que de
politique avec des footballeur des
journalistes des acteurs mais en faire
ok on est d'accord
le soir même
on sort chirac
donc les textes des guignols arrivé à
18h sur le bureau de greffe et de
lescure donc il nous a pas interdit de
le faire c'est très important
20 heures c'est diffusé chirac est donc
à l'antenne
et mon téléphone sonne à 20h03
jamais un téléphone noir un peu de
bureaux quoi mais qui est important et
je veux marquer présidence je décroche
il ya son assistante qui me dit
pierrette par les jeudis voyagement
doute je prends le téléphone est là
c'est une bordée d'injures monumentale
mais d'injures d'injures t'as pas
de paroles tu vas premier un truc tu le
tiens pas atteint et je le laisse crier
ça dure trente bonnes secondes
d'engueulades de téléphone et je lui dis
mais pierre on n'a pas sorti d'hommes
politiques on a montré le président de
la république c'est pas un homme
politique c'est le président de tous les
français il n'a rien à faire dans une
élection législative
il n'est notre président lui il n'est
pas concerné il ya un blanc dit pauvre
con et raccroche
le lendemain
on
en fait une lucarne ce qui là la petite
lucarne noir qui avait et je me souviens
plus exactement ce qu'on a dit mais on
montrait alain de greef et pierre
lescure et on disait depuis qu'ils n'ont
plus droit de sortir des marionnettes
politiques les auteurs des guignols il
on chie
et pierre dise un truc chez plus quoi et
de grève disait 5 de sécuriser 5 kw à 5
secondes tu as parlé donc cinq secondes
pour la droite
je retourne dans mon bureau 8h03
téléphone président je décroche c'était
drôle connard et un croche et je me suis
toujours dit ça c'est un bon patron
parce que le texte il avait avant il
aurait pu dire vous faites pas ça il n'a
jamais fait ça il nous a laissé faire il
nous engueuler après il nous a parfois
pas demandé d'arrêter
mais il a été
persuasif et il avait raison sur un méli
mauresmo par exemple aux guignols
ont fait
il ya une fille qui travaillait aux
guignols qui est resté en moi sophie
fontanel
qui dirigent ou qui travaille maintenant
dans des journaux féminins elle a essayé
de travailler un mois aux guignols et
moi je voulais absolument qui est une
fille ce que quand tu mets quatre mecs
dans une pièce ça devient un vestiaire
de foot il ya un moment c'est comme ça
qu'on peut pas faire autrement
enfin on pourrait me n'est pas assez
intelligent pour le faire sur la durée
et donc on commence à travailler autour
de l'idée que amélie mauresmo
elle serait mieux dans le tennis
masculin c'est l'été baraki comme ça
mais on oublie juste un truc c'est que
ce qui nous fait penser ça c'est qu'à
l'époque on parle de dopage dans le
tennis notamment et qu'un des premiers
signes de dopage c'est le menton
supercars et quand tu te dope à mort et
qui pour des trucs tellement ton car il
ya un dossier c'est plus compliqué il
faut aller les chercher oui mais on ne
va pas parler de ça on n'a pas les
photos ça serait dommage mais donc nous
on a dans notre tête dopage mais on
oublie d'en parler et on commence à rire
avec l'idée qu'elle a une voix comme ça
de mec est tout et c'est sophie fontanel
qui trouve les vannes sur amélie
mauresmo et on rigole on rigole on
rigole donc on fait ça le lundi le mardi
le mercredi le jeudi sort paris match
est à la une de paris match et amélie
mauresmo et sa fiancée elle dit voilà je
vis avec une femme je suis homosexuel le
vendredi tout le monde nous disait vous
êtes homophobe parce que vous lui mettez
une voix de mec alors le fait qu'elle
soit là on avait commencé avant
et là on commence à s'empêtrer et comme
on est taquin on se dit on n'arrête pas
on va pas arrêter parce que elle dit
qu'elle est homosexuelle ça la regarde
c'est sa vie nous ça nous concerne pas
enfants le droit à l'indifférence
et donc on continue et au bout de huit
jours mais on se prend des volets mais
vraiment homophobes dans tous les coins
et lescure viennent me voir elle lui dit
elle a fait quoi de mal cette dame
âgée pour pourquoi tu dis ça
c'est drôle ce que vous faites
franchement ça me fait rire mais elle
fait quoi cette dame quel pouvoir est là
quel pouvoir de nuisance est là sur la
société qui mérite que tous les jours
elle soit à l'antenne et que tous les
jours vous foutiez de sa gueule
suis banon mais rien et c'est marrant
oui mais quel pouvoir elle a
aucun
est-ce que je vous emmerde sur les gens
qui ont du pouvoir jamais non
voilà je vous dis pas d'arrêter un mais
si vous levez le pied moi je serais
content et elle aussi et vous vous serez
plus intelligent de la sortie donc on
fait réunir duo à tomber il veut nous
interdire il veut censurer puis au bout
d'un moment on discute on se dit non
mais il a raison au fait qu'est-ce
qu'est ce qu'elle a à voir avec la
marche du monde cette dame rien donc on
lui a foutu la peine
je te lance une question puis je vais
les voir y ait quelqu'un qui vient
questionner nos portes
c'est pratique et c'est que t'as vu que
les gens rentrent est ce que est ce que
au 21ème siècle ta liberté de ton la
liberté de ton de certains humoristes
on est attaqué tellement attaqué qu'on
peut plus rien dire on ne peut plus
fonctionner on peut plus critiqués on
peut plus ou de la gueule des gens pour
report de l'humour
oui
oui c'est mais ils peuvent le faire ils
le font pas
ils peuvent le faire mais ils ne font
pas
il y en a qui le font
eboué il fait des trucs pas mal
blanche gardin elle fait des trucs
il ya des humoristes qui essaye encore
de faire des choses
mais
à la télévision c'est plus difficile
pourquoi je sais pas c'est l'autocensure
qui fait ça c'est pas il n'y a pas
vraiment une censure il ya personne qui
dit ne faut pas on dit juste si tu fais
ou si tu veux faire mon ce style là ben
tu passeras beaucoup moins
à l'antenne donc du coup ben
ils vont plutôt parler des rapports
hommes femmes
se dire vous avez vu les gens
quand il y à une femme
c'est difficile moi je n'arrive pas à
rentrer en boîte des trucs qui n'ont pas
d'intérêt mais des humoristes qui font
vraiment de la politique ou qui font
vraiment du sociétal et qui rentre dans
le lard sur la religion le le fric il y
en a très peu aux guignols mon regret
mon plus gros regret c'est de ne pas
avoir réussi à imposer de faire tous les
patrons du cac 40 sont les connais pas
ces gens si tu les prends tu vas aller
montrer un petit peu en disant on va
c'est lui qui fait les choses c'est pas
le politique que sur qui on tape le
politique y est ils ont renoncé à faire
des choses depuis bien longtemps mais
ceux qui sont derrière ceux qui
financent ceux qui font que le monde est
comme il est ils sont dirigés c'est lui
voilà pourquoi tu dis que les politiques
ont renoncé depuis bien longtemps à
faire des choses
sint c'est presque c'est mathématique je
vous avais bien les maths ici en fait
tu as entendu parler de ce truc le think
tank c'est terra nova qui avait théorisé
que les classes populaires étaient soit
parti chez le pen soit de voter plus et
que donc ce n'était pas la peine de s'y
intéresser parce qu'on perdait du temps
à le faire et que tous les partis
politiques dans une courbe de gauss
comme ça ils vont chercher là où l
électorat et sur 49 millions d'électeurs
je crois possiblement il y en a que 20
millions qui votent en gros
régulièrement donc il faut aller taper
là dedans si tu veux être élu mais pour
être élu il faut que tu es un programme
consensuel qui fait en sorte qu' on se
dise je vais voter pour lui parce qu'il
a une belle gueule je vais voter sur
pour lui parce que sur des problèmes
sociétaux comme la pma ou
l'homosexualité il est plus sympa que
l'autre mais au fond
politiquement
économiquement
ils se rejoignent
et si on est aux extrêmes et si on va
chercher très à gauche ou très à droite
on perd du monde c'est pour ça que le fn
se et rain man il s'appelle se recentre
beaucoup
parce que s'ils veulent des électeurs il
faut qu'ils aillent chercher là où il y
en a
très à gauche ou très à droite y en a
plus y en a pas un apparat c'est donc
ils sont obligés de de tous faire le
même type de politique la quintessence
de sa est en macro qui est gauche et
droite donc il ramasse tout
il a
[Musique]
un discours qui est d'un creux quand tu
le regardes bien monumentale
mais il est bien dit
alors on se dit bah pourquoi pas au long
de cette es mort fillon avait explosé en
vol mélenchon visiblement la france on
veut pas enfin il n'y a pas assez de
gens pas de gens assez nombreux pour le
pour les lire et macron il a réussi à
a regroupé autour de lui tous les
décideurs tous les mecs qui ont du fric
et qu'ils ont fabriqué en deux ans 3
bâle iii et puis voilà il est président
ou encore huit ans tu vas être réélu un
joule annonce garde là celle-là
sur la politique
et je vous rassure le des guignols et en
moins de dix minutes je suis déjà sur la
politique l étudiant j'étais un peu
politique quand même non
avant tous trois comptent dans un bureau
qui disait des conneries et
qui avait juste eu huit heures pour
réfléchir à ce qu'ils allaient dire
alors que n'importe quel autre citoyen
français baïla du travail il a sa
famille à s'occuper et donc il n'a pas
le temps d'y penser mais je pense que
beaucoup auraient pu faire ce qu'on dit
mais avec moins de talent
charte est jeté
mais c'est pour justifier le salaire
qu'ils nous ont filé pendant des années
c'est ce milieu où dit on
plus + 33 mille brut
ou là alors je c'est compliqué à dire ça
faisait aux alentours ma paye à moi ma
dernière paye mai dernier mon dernier
contrat ces quatre cent mille euros net
par an ce qui fait une fois que tu as
payé tes cotisations tes impôts un
pouvoir d'achat de 100 mille euros à peu
près à l'année aux guignols je pense que
c'était un peu plus parce qu'il y avait
des droits d'auteur qui venait s'ajouter
il y avait la paix y était beaucoup
beaucoup moins forte que ce que j'avais
à la fin mais les droits d'auteur
compenser je crois qu'on gagnait un peu
plus que ça on doit gagner aux alentours
de wet 30 30 35 mille balles par mois
c'est pas mal on était content à rennes
35 tu es tranquille
mais bon tu payes et pas de pas
d'évasion fiscale qui j'en ai fait ça à
adjamé d'optimisation fiscale tout ce
qui va avec alors l'optimisation fiscale
ça n'existe pas c'est de l'évasion
fiscale mais c'est la façon polie de
d'organiser l'évasion au fait mais ce
qui compense de ça on va revenir sur la
politique et maghrébine a un peu après
mais il à l'évasion fiscale
un crime contre l'humanité non mais
c'est quelque chose de terrible c'est
quelque chose de terrible on vit dans un
monde qui n'a jamais
produit autant de richesses
et avec ça après on peut parler de sa
forêt je développe ça après par ailleurs
mais on a besoin de moins en moins de
gens pour faire tourner la machine il ya
deux façons de répartir les richesses y
en a pas 150 mètres de la première c'est
par l'impôt en créant des services
publics efficient qui
qui sont partout qui maillent le
territoire ce qui fait que si on a une
petite paye et bien c'est pas grave
c'est quand on est malade quand on veut
aller à l'école quand on veut être
protégés quand on veut rouler sur des
routes qui fonctionnent les services
publics font en sorte que le pays soit
agréable à vivre même quand on n'a pas
beaucoup d'argent et qu'on ne meurt pas
donc ça c'est les impôts donc l'évasion
fiscale in fine et tuent des gens
et l'autre moyen
c'est d'augmenter les salaires
sauf que ces deux moyens là
on ne les met jamais en place l'évasion
fiscale ont dit si on taxe trop les gens
compte tenu de la mondialisation ils
vont se barrer
et si on augmente les salaires compte
tenu de la dette je parle la dette
privée sur la dette publique ça peut
être un investissement puisque c'est
l'état qui l'a garanti et que il ya
quand même un pays derrière
mais la dette privée empêche d'augmenter
les salaires parce que toute pme ou tpe
qui a comme premier souci de rembourser
sa dette ne peut pas augmenter les
salaires parce qu'elle diminue sa marge
voire même elle est déficitaire
donc plus elle gagne d'argent plus les
comptes en plus elle rembourse sa dette
mais elle n'investit jamais elle peut
pas ces mécaniques donc l'autre moyen
c'est l'évasion fils et l'évasion
fiscale c'est la fiscalité
mais il n'y a pas un politique
aujourd'hui qui est la réelle volonté de
s'attaquer à l'évasion fiscale surtout
pas macron parce que c'est ses potes il
va pas les taxes et même il leur a rendu
de l'argent de la supprimer les sf
formidable et il dit je suis pas le
président des riches le mec est
extraordinaire quoi là
hier il a fait taper sur les pompiers
ont dû rebondir c'est par lui
directement il ya quand même des crs qui
ont gazé des pompiers c'est un petit
impôt qu on fait ça non ah oui j'étais
ouais je me suis dit j'ai dit ça sur
twitter je me suis fait engueuler s'il
ya des gens qui étaient très premier
degré à la team premier degré qui ne
suis moi je les adore génie en fait ces
services publics fonctionnent bien en
france tu payes des flics avec tes
impôts qui vont taper sur des
pompiers que tu payes tes impôts au
moins on voit les services publics dans
la rue voilà on les voit ils sont là il
ya un mec qui m'a dit ouais je peux pas
dire ça
twitte tu craches sur les services
publics
l'humour et paf toujours par écrit ça
passe pas bien le second degré a décrit
sa passe difficile
depuis on va rentrer un peu plus dans
dur là à le le pays va où le pays va mal
le pays va bien le est-ce qu'on va la
guerre civile est ce que tu sans toi en
tant qu'humoriste que les gens se
tendent à y mourir de hauteur auteur qui
a l'élégance d'essayer de faire drôle
mais où va le pays une contenu que je le
sache le pays il est riche c'est une
phrase de coluche les gens vont être
contents les pauvres vont être contents
qu'ils habitent un pays riche mais le
pays est riche il est très riche nos
deux pays pourtant il est peuplé
9 millions de gens qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté devrait d'ailleurs
c'est le journée internationale contre
les visées un pas super et une journée
pour ça avec la journée du cheval la
journée de la femme journée du pays à
des journées pour tous et toutes la
journée qu'il faut 20 toute l'année
qu'il faut parler des femmes de toute
l'année mais où ils valent pays
en tout cas il est énervé et on parle
bien de la france parce qu'avec 1000
balles en indonésie on est le roi du
pétrole donc on parle de nous
mais
alors après je vais passer pour un mec
d'extrême droite c'est quoi un pays
qu'est ce que c'est notre pays
un pays c'est un
[Musique]
d'abord c'est des frontières une langue
c'est vrai de guy môquet c'est la lettre
de guy môquet ou
way 17 ans y meurent non je préfère
bousquet au moins lui il est mort à 80
piges non c'est une blague c'est une
blague arrêté bon
un pays normalement ça peut battre
monnaie
et ça a une armée pour se défendre
et ça commerce avec d'autres pays à côté
qu'il reconnaisse en tant que pays donc
on dit qu'il est souverain
en france on ne peut plus battre monnaie
nos frontières sont a priori du côté de
schengen et personne ne sait ce que
celle l'espace schengen qui peut me dire
exactement où est la frontière moi je
vois bien les pyrénées les alpes
l'atlantique la méditerranée
les belges comme on peut wen et beige
bon voilà
sa joie bien schengen jeu personne ne
peut dire il ya très peu de gens qui
peuvent dire exactement où ça passe donc
on n'a pas de frontières on peut pas
battre monnaie
on a une armée et une force de frappe
nucléaire qui est basé sur quatre ou
cinq je crois maintenant sous marins
nucléaires dont personne ne sait où ils
sont et c'est ça la dissuasion
mais on a intégré au commandement de
l'otan
du coup
est ce que ça fonctionne vraiment en
plus on vient de vendre j'ai suivi ça
sur situe au fioul on vient de vendre
j'ai oublié le nom
notre technologie en fait
on s'est fait un peu on s'est fait
braquer on s'est fait braquer west of
voilà alstom ont fait un poil fait
braquer de la technologie qui se
retrouvent dans les missiles qui se
retrouvent dans le nucléaire qui se
retrouvent dans l'informatique tout ça
on s'est un peu fait braquer ça donc on
peut pas dire
qu'on a vraiment une armée non plus
et puis après on a une langue
sauf dans les affaires où tout le monde
parle anglais ça dépend quel type
d'affaires sa battue par oui si on va du
côté de l'afrique
mais man financier délaissé le marché ne
parle que français c'est vrai tu me la
prend mais quand même la langue des
affaires je pensais que c'était plus
l'anglais mois de la langue de la
diplomatie
le français la vraie la langue du fric
et des affaires s'est pas l'anglais en
tout cas je tremblais en scylla c'est le
franglais quand même
et notre culture française millénaire
où va ce abonnés à netflix pour regarder
house of cards voilà c'est ça notre donc
eu notre souveraineté elle est très
relative
et j'ai entendu j'ai même écrit un truc
sur facebook tellement ça m'a énervé ce
j'écris les papiers sont facebook très
long et
j'ai entendu que
monsieur macron recevait madame merkel a
toulouse je crois pour parler de la
souveraineté européenne
comment on peut parler de souveraineté
européenne l'union européenne
est un
agglomérat de nation mais elle n'est pas
un pays
pourtant en matière
en tout financière j'allais dire
économique mais en matière financière et
en matière de politique économique elle
a tous les attributs d'un pays elle peut
imposer à des pays des
directions économique mais pas fiscal et
que la fiscalité qu'on a sorti ce qui
permet un dumping fiscal à l'intérieur
de l'europe
donc où va le pays
un énervement global mais cet énervement
global on le doit
la passivité intellectuelle des gens ont
la passivité intellectuelle des gens
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent les gens
j'aimerais bien celui de dignité ben oui
mais j'ai la dignité ça passe aussi par
un petit peu d'implication dans les
choses c'est un peu compliqué d'aller
demander à quelqu'un à qui tu dis ton
travail ça va être mille balles par mois
dans le meilleur des cas si tu as un
travail et il faut que tu t'intéresses
au pays non je m'intéressais à bouffer
mais tout ça c'est
passé par un complot international mais
c'est quand même bien foutu il ya quand
même quelques
quelques économistes et quelques
philosophes et quelques penseurs adam
smith ricardo tous ces gens l'école de
chicago c'est tous des gens qui ont
théorisé ça même marx a théorisé le
chômage il a dit pour le capitalisme il
faut qu'il y ait plein de chômeurs s'il
ya plein de chômeurs c'est ce qu'il
appelait une armée de réserve donc il ya
plein de chômeurs on va puiser dans
l'armée de réserve et quand il y en
aurait qui dit j'aimerais bien un
salaire un peu plus élevé tu sais ce que
tu vas faire tu vas prendre la porte et
puis il y en a 50 qui attendent derrière
donc où va le pays il va vers la
compréhension de sa de plus en plus les
gilet jaune c'est ça c'est des gens qui
ont compris qu'on s'occupait pas de et
les gilet jaune on les a traités de tous
les noms ils ont été aux mots forts
antisémites racistes d'extrême droite
d'extrême gauche a été tout
sauf que depuis quelques semaines il ya
des flics dans la rue il ya des
infirmières dans la rue il ya les
pompiers dans la rue et encore ils sont
descendus juste avec le casque et la
combine
jour ils descendent avec les camions en
hausse et les flics qui recule
donc tous ces gens qui sont un autre
service les infirmiers j'ai fait une
embolie pulmonaire il ya trois ans
s'ils sont pas là je suis mort
je n'aurais pas pu faire ces interviews
les pompiers
combien de fois on appelle les pompiers
pour venir sortir quelque chose qui est
dans un dans une canalisation parce
qu'on ne sait pas qui on doit appeler on
appelle les pompiers ils arrivent ils
font un peu d'ailleurs c'est pas
nous c'est le plombier mais ils font le
job
combien de fois ils ont sorti des gens
des flammes combien sont morts en
sauvant des vies et là ils vont dire on
aimerait bien qu'on revalorise un peu
nos salaires et qu'on regarde nos
conditions de travail et on leur envoie
des crs avec qui son copain parce qu'ils
sont sur les mêmes interventions
l'ailé quand tu vois un camion de
pompier généralement à côté il ya un
camion flics parce qu'il ya un accident
parce que les flics font la circulation
les pompiers soigne sur place et là ils
se tapent dessus enfin surtout les les
pauvres en bleu qui tape sur les pauvres
en rouge sont pas si pour ce que ça les
mecs en bleu non à ben on leur file
quand même ouais jésus-christ mis le
petit prix mais la prime de 200 euros le
week-end il y les pompiers ou s'ils vont
toucher à l'horizon la toucher aux et
ils l'ont déjà touché
et ils vont violer dans la rue
c'est sûr de ça peut-être pas pour les
mêmes choses non mais quelle est pour la
retraite choses comme ça les retraites
mais quelle retraite
mais quelle retraite moi je vais être
traitée bientôt j'ai touché un gros
salaire pendant toute ma fin de toute ma
vie j'ai 25 ans de ma vie
gdg cotiser mais de façon monumental
pour le moment où je serai au chômage là
je suis chômeur ce mon statut je suis
chômeur et je touche le maximum de ce
qu'on peut toucher au chômage quelque
1500 euros 2005 5000 oiseaux autour de
5000 balle
mais j'ai fait un calcul avec un copain
jo on s'amusait il ya des gens qui me
reprochent c'est vrai tu te rends compte
et au chômage tandis que tu prends jeudi
mais pendant 25 ans j'ai cotisé et mon
employeur a cotisé juston cotisations
hauteur d'à peu près 30 mille balles par
mois plus les impôts donc j'ai dû
cotiser à hauteur de en gros allez on va
dire 40 45 mille balles par mois c'est à
la louche je fais ça en euros
là on me rend 5000 par mois parce que
j'ai eu un accident de la vie je n'ai
pas demandé à être chauffeur moi on m'a
mis au chômage on m'a dit tu travailles
plus ici pour quelles raisons il y en a
pas
voilà je travaille plus mais j'ai pas
demandé à y être mais pendant tout ce
temps où j'ai donné j'ai cotisé beaucoup
j'ai aidé des gens qui étaient qui
subissaient cet accident de la vie aussi
je les ai aidé et j'ai jamais crier
contre ça au contraire le mec passe pas
de 10 à 0 il s'écroule pas il ya des
paliers après s'ils travaillent pas
pendant dix ans c'est sûr qu'il va avoir
plus de mal mais il a le temps de se
retourner c'est un
c'est un pays social quoi qui s'occupe
de ses habitants mais depuis sarkozy ça
a commencé avec sarkozy
sarkozy hollande macron
cd techno pour qui le pays est une
entreprise
est un pays c'est pas une entreprise un
pays s'est peuplée de gens très
différents
faut faire vivre ensemble tous ces gens
les hommes les femmes les grands les
petits les crocs les intelligents les
érudits les imbéciles tout le monde doit
vivre ensemble
sauf que la gestion de l'idiot du
village aujourd'hui elle est nulle moi
j'ai vécu dans un village pendant un
moment là où j'avais un restaurant près
d'eygalières
il y avait des idiots du village intégré
trc des gens qui avaient
c'est pas du mépris social ce que je
vais faire mais c'est une réalité que
j'ai constatées dans ce village là en
tout cas il ya des gens qui avaient des
capacités intellectuelles limitées
des envies limité il n'avait pas envie
de s'impliquer de travailler comme des
bêtes
mais ils étaient intégrés
c'est à dire qu'
il allait ramasser les feuilles
il aller aux champignons yvan dessau
blacks au restaurant il allait nettoyer
les piscines des riches quand il fallait
les rouvrir il s'occupait
d'être utile à ce village et ils
allaient jouer aux cartes avec le maire
et le maire leur disais j'ai que tu as
joué pitch dedycker a jusque use mois et
qui est vraiment trop con mais il était
avec le maire ils étaient intégrés
et il savait qu'ils seraient jamais
l'instit ou le pharmacien ou médecin ou
chef d'entreprise il le savait mais ils
étaient intégrés et ils pouvaient vivre
avec l'instit le médecin et chefs
d'entreprise aujourd'hui où ils sont où
est ce qu'ils se croisent ces gens
jamais
moi j'ai plein de potes à la télé qui
sont dans le fond j'ai plus de potes à
la tipp en fait
qu'ils sont dans le mépris de classe
monumentale et quand moi je le dise le
samedi je suis allé e gelé manifester et
gilet jaune sur les 48 ou 49 on en est
là j'ai dû en faire une vingtaine je
suis allé je me suis fait gazer
bon bah tu cours c'est tout tu te barres
et ils disent mais qu'est ce que tu vas
faire avec cette bande de cons et c'est
c'est des gens qui juste 10 je veux
vivre au mieux ils sont pas en train de
te voler quelque chose ils disent juste
prenez nous en considération on existe
et oui 10 pour ac t'occupe pas de ces
conviant va jouer au golf
d'accord demain vous coûte mépris comme
ça dans la télé énorme
énorme c'est du même genre que les mecs
de wall street qui sommes une petite
coupe de champagne en regardant les gars
de occupy wall street en bas c'est ça
ouais wyatt ça mais tu sais en nous on
nous parlait de la boulangère périlleux
toi ne fait pas ça à la télé ils vont
rien comprendre dans le cantal
il comprenait bien les guignols dans le
conte annonce n'était pas de leur gueule
et très honnêtement tout l'époque où
j'ai vécu à canal+ que je vivais
carrément un canal + j'ai jamais vu des
gens se foutent de la gueule du public
pas parce que peut-être qu'il y avait du
mépris aussi mais il était enfoui parce
que c'était des clients c'est des gens
qui paient un abonnement et notre modèle
économique à canal était de satisfaire
des clients le mec qui avait payé le 1er
janvier ils avaient payé chacun jusqu'à
31 décembre donc on n'avait pas besoin
d'aller le chercher tous les soirs il
fallait juste le satisfaire et cette
façon d'aborder la télévision faisait
qu' on se disait qu'est ce qui va les
satisfaire alors comment on peut faire
ils ont envie de quoi
alors on va pas chercher de quoi ils ont
envie on va chercher des gens capables
de les comprendre parce qu'ils viennent
du même endroit jean françois halin
venait de nantes milieu très modeste
jean france benoît delépine fils de
paysan dans le nord un picard moi je
viens fils de maçon il italien immigré
de saint-etienne ont parlé de
parisianisme ne nous parlait pas je
serais passé très loin non souhaitait
pas de leur gueule parce qu'on savait
qu'il y avait nos potes qui regardaient
et puis il ya des dérives on arrive à
bas c'est des cons faut leur donner ce
qu'ils veulent ils veulent quoi du cul
et de la violence d'honneur pour ça
qu'on faisait tf1 du cul du cul du cul
le cul fait vendre seront ils avaient
fait ça camembert le q10
qui se passe à cat et maintenant on leur
donne que ça c'est à dire qu'on on
utilise les parties de leurs cerveaux
les plus primitives
alors pour leur vendre du temps de
cerveau disponible pour s'accaparer du
temps de cerveau disponible
le jour où patrick le lay a dit ça il
nous a rendu un fier service parce qu'il
a validé tous qu'on disait aux guignols
il a validé d'un coup mon boulot c'est
de vendre du temps de cerveau disponible
à coca cola
mais il ya des bouquins je le train ou à
d'autres riches du coca cola parce que
c'est ce qui lui a fait dire mais
xavier couture qui a été à un moment
alors je sais plus exactement son
possible d'être président à canal à un
moment
avait écrit un livre où il expliqué dans
ce livre comment on construisait un jt
et un jt alors je le fais de mémoire
s'est longtemps gelé par lui depuis
longtemps mais un jt doit commencer par
quelque chose par une information de
proximité
on commence par un fait divers de
pourquoi parce que ça me parle ça peut
m'arriver
ensuite on passe à un problème
social qui dit en gros c'est la merde
partout
vous n'êtes pas protégé c'est une
catastrophe puis on passe à
l'international très court pour dire
regardez c'est pire ailleurs
tout ça dans un seul but 7 novembre
le médicament qui va bien après la
publicité et la consommation tu es dans
un pays où tu peut consommer achète une
voiture achètent des disques achète une
machine à laver achète à manger achètent
tout ce que tu veux et c'est çà çà çà çà
va te rendre heureux et les gens une
fois qu'ils sont bien en panique ils
vont acheter ça les soulage compulsive
ouais mais le truc a été étudié dans un
séminaire il raconte ça hein c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est lui qui leur
raconte faudrait vérifier je comprends
votre communauté fait ça tout le temps
vérifier c'est xavier couture
il avait théorisé ça il ya eu un
séminaire dans lequel sont venues des
sociologues des philosophes des
ethnologues des comptes
comportementaliste pour dire le public
tu lui fait peur
puis tout le soulage et pour lui faire
peur faut que la peur soit globale faut
qu'ils se sentent on pourrait donc
proximité service public qui marchent
pas bien des grèves partout un truc
internationale pour dire ailleurs c'est
pire ne bougerai pas d'ici et à les
consommer
c'est bernese cesser les trucs de
bernese la propaganda ouais bon livre
l'alto constat sur l'information va
revenir un petit peu sur l'année
dernière sur in
les médias qui se vautre avec la sphère
du terroriste planqué à la drpp laura
coup c'est une lame en céramique puis
après c'est plus une âme en céramique
puis la clé usb était chez lui puis en
fait elle est plus chez lui aller au
bureau et puis en fait il a passé deux
couteaux coûte 33 cm et un couteau et by
trees et en métal bon ils sont ils sont
un petit peu votre et avec des
approximations et la dernière en date
qui nous a bien marqué c'est le monsieur
qui s'est fait attraper par la police en
écosse le lou est un tueur
cette merveille tueur de toute sa
famille hop ils ont tous titrés bon
c'est parce que quoi ils sont dans le
ruck il ya plein de gens qui travaillent
ça vient de quoi les deux les deux ils
sont dans le rush il faut absolument que
j'ai l'info qu'est ce que va faire le
voisin donc là voisins a dit qu'il y
avait un couteau avant moi j'ai une info
il y en a deux ah bon il ya deux
couteaux et le mec qui à l'antenne dans
l'oreillette il ya deux couteaux il y
aurait deux couteaux petit
conditionnelle pour se bat pour ce bac
est un peu quand il dit quand ils le
pren sinon ils ne font pas toujours ils
sont obligés d'être dans le rouge puis
réfléchissent après mais pierre lazareff
disait cette chose très juste une fausse
info est un démenti ces deux infos donc
voilà comment ils avancent c'est pour ça
et aussi parce que je crois que c'est
qui est-ce qui se fout toujours sur les
réseaux sociaux de la gueule du
stagiaire de bfm parce que le mec qui
tape les il fait des fautes
d'orthographe moi j'en fais je suis ok
mais le mec tapis lille faute
d'orthographe et il tape n'importe quoi
les bons titres c'est n'importe quoi ça
n'a pas de sens souvent et
pourquoi parce que le stagiaire bas il
- payer
il n'a pas le temps de chercher il n'a
pas le temps de vérifier parce qu'il
faut coller aux autres par l'info aux
autres chaînes d'info et après ça sera
celui qui sera le plus crapoteux dans
les commentaires et aujourd'hui moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas du tout
passé pas de l'information les chaînes
d'info déjà ça je n'apprends rien à
personne mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est même un moyen de communiquer entre
grands groupes industriels
qu'est ce que tu penses de ça voyons
voir ce que mon concurrent dit dans sa
chaîne d'info et dans sa chaîne d'info
il dit en bois la guerre en syrie c'est
très bien là hier en syrie c'est pas
bien l'étudiante s'est nos copains et
les kurdes cèdent pas nos copains et
j'ai l'impression qu'ils communiquent
entre eux est en fait au niveau
information
moi je ne sais pas exactement ce qui se
passe avec les turcs
en syrie je ne sais pas trop ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire avec les kurdes
il les laisse crever oui ça c'est le
truc qu'on dit moi je suis beaucoup paul
moreira qui a beaucoup travaillé dans
ces zones là ouais épaules il twitte en
disant j'ai une info comme ça elle n'est
pas recoupé elle vient que d'un seul
canal mais c'est tout à fait plausible
pour telle ou telle raison telle ville
dans laquelle je suis allée qui est
comme ça comme ça et comme ça est en
train de tomber ou résiste là il ya une
contre attaque et je les écoute lui je
veux pas à l'écouté des gens
dans lci bfm ou ses news ou même france
info quoi j'ai l'impression france info
est moins pire mais j'en suis même pas
sûr j'en suis même pas sûre qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire c'est le prix offert il
faut faire vous mais je dis ça j'ai des
salles où il faut pas faire quand 12 ans
mais j'ai dit ça c'est bien la hache
mais c'est comme ça ça fonctionne les
guignols c'est parti à larache ils nous
ont pas vu arriver et puis on a commencé
à déconner sur la guerre du golfe il ya
eu à un moment
discussion aux guignols qui était mais
semble a raconté j étais pas encore
s'est il y avait mille das lescure de
greef toujours les mêmes qu'est ce qu'on
fait on arrête les guignols pendant la
guerre du golfe parce que le bébête show
s'était arrêté il avait pris le deuil ou
carrément mieux la france est en guerre
on arrête on peut plus rire et je sais
pas lequel des patrons a dit mais non
c'est l'occasion au contraire de se
démarquer il faut le traiter
intelligemment et on a des auteurs
intelligent je n'étais pas à l'époque
donc c'est d'autant plus facile pour moi
de le dire
qu'ils vont traiter ça bien et ils
entrent était bien donc les gens sont
venus regarder ce qu'on disait et ça a
été
on sent vraiment un déplacement du
bébête show vers les guignols parce que
c'était mieux fait mieux écrit mieux
penser donc pourquoi il serait allé
regarder des gens qui parlent dans un
bistrot c'est ce qu'ils font maintenant
ils vont regarder des gens qui parlent
dans un bistrot
donc ils n'ont pas vu venir
vous c'est pareil vous ça commence à
larache et puis ça fait quand même des
millions de vues il ya des millions de
gens qui regardent votre truc
le média
ça commence sa panique c'est la télé de
mélenchon qui roule dedans il ya un
mille rcc la france insoumise tout le
monde tape dessus moi je leur disais les
gars c'est bien qui vous tape dessus
parce que tout le monde sait qu'il ya un
truc qui s'appelle le média bon
maintenant c'est tout pourri ce que vous
faites il est temps de faire quelque
chose de bien prenez le temps mais vous
avez le temps prenez le et faites ce que
vous voulez en fait le seul moyen s'il
ya quelque chose à faire grâce à
internet grâce à ses autres canaux de
diffusion
c'est d'essayer de ringardiser ces gens
faut juste plus que les gens les
regardent ou alors ce qui se passe
maintenant enfin 80000 personnes devant
quoi c'est que dalle je suis sûr qu'on
va faire plus mais c'est que dalle donc
il faut juste
tenir être tenace et c'est pas fastoche
parce que les moyens sont pas là parce
que on est mal payé quand on fait ça
mais si on croit qu'on peut faire
quelque chose d'utile ou de marant ou de
politiques peu importe faut le faire
faut pas lâcher la faire c'est comme ça
que ont ré gars disent les autres parce
que les gens ont juste se dire quand je
regarde think i review
je suis satisfait beaucoup plus que
quand je regarde une chaîne d'info en
continu
moi je parle de signes kerriou parce que
je suis là si j'étais aux médias je
dirais la même chose des médias ou de là
bas si j'y suis ou de mediapart même
pourquoi même
parce qu'ils seront pas blanc bleu sur
certains trucs mais ils sont très forts
ils ont réussi à faire un truc
rentable bien foutu documenté et
inattaquable tous les politiques qui
essaye de leur rentrer dedans et il se
ramasse le juge à la finlande
on va on va revenir sur les guignols
donc il y avait le matin le matin une
revue de presse vous épluchez la presse
que ce soit la presse régionale locale
ou nationale ou internationale
non non moi je lisais des rapports de
l'insee ah ouais moi je suis un
chercheur
mais je lisais le monde diplo pour le
pour avoir une vision un peu plus
étoffé de ce qui se passait dans le
monde et donc ceux qui allaient
probablement arriver en france
je lisais des balais rapport de l'insee
les statistiques j'adorais ça
quand tu apprends qu'il ya des pauvres
et que tu es dans un pays riche faut que
tu ailles voir combien il ya de pauvres
pourquoi ils sont pauvres depuis combien
de temps elles sont pauvres est-ce que
ça va encore durer un peu qui dit qu'ils
sont pauvres d'ailleurs et qui les met
dans la danse dans une certaine classe
et pourquoi pas d'autres et ainsi de
suite c'est churchill qui disait je ne
crois qu'aux statistiques que j'ai
moi-même trafic et bien sûr
et donc moi je vais poser une question
pour rire d'une info il faut l'avoir
subie
j'ai déjà dit ça ouais t'as déjà dit ça
donc c'est une phrase qui m'a vraiment
marqué à force de lire toutes ces infos
faire une revue de presse comment le
mental survie
je vais féliciter mes copains des
guignols c'est que
et je parle de toutes les équipes et
alexandre charlot et franck magnier
ahmed hamidi lionel dutemple julien
hervé c'est tout ce que avec qui j'ai
vécu
quand il y en a un qui avait un coup de
mou les autres tenait
et le fait d'être une bande et de ceux
de se tenir et d'être toujours
bienveillant avec celui qui va moins
bien et le moins bien peut durer dix
jours
plus ou plus mais non nous ça durait pas
trop en fait quand ça j'ai quand c'était
vraiment difficile on allait jouer au
foot dans les couloirs on l'emmerdé tous
les autres bureaux mais au moins on
était tranquilles nous mais ouais c'est
ça qui te fait tenir c'est d'être sûr
que tu es dans une bande qui vous le
coup on se défend on se tient les uns
les autres et puis je parle des auteurs
mais elle est manipulateur les
imitateurs toutes les tous les gens qui
salit costumes les maquilleuses quoi
avec qui on travaille et qui étaient en
bas qui venait nous dire ah c'était bien
hier moi j'ai pas trouvé ça si c'était
vachement bien elle lâchait pas la faire
et tout ça j'ai vu ça vous savez ce
qu'on a dit vous cédez c'est pas
vrai âge et le fait d'être une bande et
de se tenir
ça fonctionne
et en plus on avait
on n'a eu pratiquement jusqu'à fin mois
jusqu'à la fin des patrons
alors exceptionnelle avec de greffer
lescure
acceptable avec belle-mère
aimé e acceptable même si on s'est frité
beaucoup plus fort avec eux ça allait il
avait compris que mes yeux quand il est
arrivé bertrand méheut qui est arrivé à
canal + je suis planqué l'année
2003 tout comme ça 2000-2003 m'avait
demandé c'est quoi canal j'avais dit
chez nous prout c'est de l'actif il
avait compris j'ai dit ok il faut les
laisser faire les cons
donc là la revue de presse comme comment
ça pouvait atteindre comment ça pouvait
être
de mettre une balle dans la tête à force
de regarder je te prends l'exemple de la
deuxième guerre en irak par exemple
les armes à uranium appauvri
les gamins qui partent on se rappelle
les gamins qui sont en mille morceaux et
derrière et à condoleezza rice qui qui
font un bon boulot
ce ce décalage comment tu le général
le je crois que le moment où j'ai été le
plus déçu pour moi même
au niveau de ma froideur
vis-à-vis des événements c'est le 11
septembre
ça se passe à 9 heures du matin chez eux
donc il est 15 heures chez nous on en
train de finaliser les jt on est en
train de l'écrire
il ya itélé à l'époque ça s'appelait
encore i télé qui est en boucle on est
là on tape des trucs recherche des
blagues et pierre nora qui fait plus
tard hier un truc qui crament on lève la
tête et on voit le world trade center
qui brûle
on allume le sont les
commentaires c'est un petit avion
se serait planté dans le world trade
center c'est un accident ça c'est les
tout premiers commentaires quand on
regarde ça et il se trouve que lionel
dutemple qui était auteur guignol à
cette époque là était chef avion dans
une précédente vie c'est à dire qu'il
est celui qui acculé le moment dans les
avions chef avion c'est celui qui dit
assez d'essence pour aller là bas et ils
calculent l'equilibre de l'aviron aussi
et donc il connaît les les circuits des
avions dans les aéroports ayant c'est
pas possible qu'un avion se plante là
c'est impossible peut pas passer par là
et moi je suis pilote de petit avion
aussi way sur le doubs sur le ventre sur
le dos sur le dos sur le ventre moi je
vole
maximum tout droit avec les oiseaux
toyer une petite lumière verte une
petite lumière rouge tu voles bien entre
les deux peut pas de bourrée je suis
projeté sur cessna 150 272 et roquettes
pour les gens qui seraient pilotes mais
je n'ai pas piloté depuis un moment
faudrait et
donc je me dis non un cessna qui rendent
dans une tour ça fais pas ça et on est
en train de débattre de ça et là on
commence à dire c'est peut-être un
attentat non quand tu ne sais pas
possible et un quart d'heure approche en
direct et là est fou deuxième avion
waouh
là tout lier une panique dans le bureau
sauf moi froid mais froid froide issime
il faut changer le jt la première chose
qui m'est venue un objet de tout changer
c'est ça qui a ce soir c'est parce qu'on
est en train de faire là ils disent mais
t'es malade il ya des gens qui meurent
et tous je dis ouais mais nous on a un
job à faire non non on peut pas ou là là
c'est la catastrophe et ça prend 10
minutes puis on commence à rire
on commence à rire à se dire en fait
c'est un pari il ya un mec qui disent ça
passe entre les deux tours non non ce
papa de 6,6 il ya un mec qui a dit et on
commence à inventer des histoires de
mecs qui disent je passe entre les deux
tours il se tape la tour pilotis lui dit
non c'est pas comme ça qu'il fallait
faire j'arrive et je vais te montrer
pour le deuxième on commence à chanter
il soit une plaine ont commencé à
déconner
et puis mais on exorcise et puis on se
dit moi je dis c'est moi qui dis ça je
dis je c'est pas parce qu'on sait pas à
l'époque ben laden al qaïda ne sais pas
je dis je sais pas quel connard qui
vient de faire ça mais il vient de nous
mettre les américains pour 50 ans sur le
dos maintenant ils vont faire ce qu'ils
veulent dans le monde entier si t'es pas
d'accord avec eux y te frappe ça va être
comme ça et on a commencé à sortir
josé bové
ou stages confort josé bové keys et moi
j'ai juste démonter un mcdo un jeu c'est
pas moi le truc tu avec nous est contre
nous non mais moi je suis là il ya des
nuances il n'y a pas de nuance est
contre nous ou tu es avec nous et toi tu
es contre nous moustache donc on va
taper
et là on s'est dit waouh c'est mort
sortant de là
je suis rentré et j'ai pensé que au jt
est là juste avant le jt c'est à dire
deux heures après il ya denisot qui
était président de canal je crois à
l'époque qui vient avec deux greffes
vous faites quoi ce soir
geo voilà ce qu'on a prévu
ça va être compliqué
pourquoi c'est notre job il ya une info
on doit la commenter non on va pas le
faire en fait on va relayer
l'information et on va faire que de
l'info on va faire que
du du 8 et léo fait on va rester sur
l'info ce soir à jeudi d'accord l ag
denisot et qui dit on passe quand même
les courses non si on passe les bois on
passe les guignols il ya on va pas
mettre le tiercé au milieu bordel et là
on à lescure au téléphone qui est à los
angeles à l'époque parce que je vous
rappelle qu'à l'époque on avait déjà dit
tu as les rois du pétrole
et pierre au téléphone il dit tu peux
pas faire un truc ce soir ici on parle
de 30 mille morts les gens sont tous
traumatisés il ya un traumatisme
terrible donc on a dit ok on fera les jt
demain le lendemain on a fait les jt
dont la le 11 septembre ya pas de jt des
guignols le 12 on fait un jt des
guignols avec ce qu'on avait prévu le 11
c'était massacre et comment ils peuvent
rire de ça les éditorialistes et
commentateurs le public non le public
c'est merci oui vous voyez le coup
d'après vous voyez arriver
le patriot act on l'a pas vu on n'a pas
écrit mais on savait que ça allait se
passer comme ça la restriction des
libertés individuelles restrictions de
l'information tout ce qui se produit
aujourd'hui
ça vient de là là on est au 21ème siècle
ça je l'avais jamais raconté là on est
au 21ème siècle est ce que tu sens une
espèce de bien pensants un mac carthysme
qui t'empêche de rire de tout qui
t'empêche de traiter certaines infos qui
t'empêche pas d'avoir un point de vue
est-ce que du sang
un socle du moins une chape de bien
pensants ce
pas comme tu l'entends déjà je l'entends
comment vas tu ne sais pas on peut plus
critiqué on peut plus on peut plus dire
des choses excessives
j'ai pas l'impression que zemmour se
prive de dire les choses excessives je
n'ai pas l'impression que goldnadel se
prive de dire des choses excessives j'ai
pas l'impression que
lci si news tous et bfm ne disent plus
des choses excessives y sont dans
l'excès en permanence simplement c'est
pas de l'excès pour moi constructif
c'est de l'excès qui a 20 ans on pouvait
pas dire ce à dire quoi de dire que les
arabes ils sont responsables et les
musulmans en tout cas son responsable de
du terrorisme les musulmans le
terrorisme il ya des terroristes
le terrorisme c'est c'est quoi c'est un
substantif abstrait on sait par le
terrorisme je peux pas lutter contre le
terrorisme ou les terroristes oui la
honteuse oui et puis musulmans égale
islam is la méga l'islamisme islamisés
gas oil tu disais ça il ya vingt piges
on disait et excuse moi tu es
complètement idiot tu fais un énorme
amalgame là aujourd'hui non si tu dis ce
que je viens de dire là on te dit tu es
un ace tu es un islamo gauchiste tu les
protège et non les gars je vois bien que
dans la religion musulmane
il y a des gens qui profitent de cette
situation pour faire un fric monstre eux
ils sont au service de je ne sais quelle
cause mortifère il faut les empêcher de
le faire mais si vous faites ce qu'il
souhaite ces terroristes là à savoir
lever le monde musulman alors vous avez
perdu on a déjà perdu d'une certaine
façon
tu sors dans la rue il ya des militaires
maintenant en france avec des
des flingues tu vas dans un aéroport tu
peux même plus passer une bouteille
d'eau
on est corseté
tout ce que tu peux dire
même en riant dans un avion tu dis non
les chaussures dont je les ai enlevés
parce qu'il ya une bombe de danse tout
au plus ils font poser l'avion
team et ils ont gagné les terroristes on
vit mal on dit sous contrôle donc ils
ont déjà gagné et vous voulez leur
donner une victoire encore plus large en
levant l'ensemble du monde musulman vous
êtes des tarés donc oui on peut dire
encore des choses excessives dans le
poste et des choses qui sont
politiquement incorrect parce que je
trouve ça très politiquement incorrect
c'est bien c'est pas bien c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien moi je trouve que le
politiquement correct
concernant
l'homosexualité
par exemple qu est ce qu il yad autres
le racisme et qu'on dise plus des choses
raciste ou des blagues racistes ou qu'on
ne se moque plus des homosexuels je
trouve ça politiquement correct ouais
mais c'est pas si mal que ça que l'on
nostra 6 plus des gens
pour une raison d'orientations sexuelles
de religion de coupe de cheveux je ne
sais je sais bien qu'on le fasse moins
ça veut dire qu'on le fait plus après
ça je te vois venir sur une scène c'est
différent
une scène c'est un sanctuaire une scène
elle doit être sanctuarisée si tu dis ou
si tu fais des décrets pour dire on peut
dire telle chose et pas telle autre
alors t'es foutu chaque fois quelqu'un
va jouer un assassin et on se retrouve
au tribunal on va le traiter lui d'
assassin non je joue un assassin après
je joue un con je joue 1
du diable oui oui mais sur une scène tu
as tous les droits
tu as tous les droits sur une scène
quand tu descends de seine si tu
poursuis le même discours à dallas est
attaquable
qu'est-ce qu'on peut plus dire alors
ce qu'on peut plus dire j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut tout dire moi
j'étais là tu as l'impression qu'ils se
privent de dire des trucs à la télé ce
qu'on peut plus dire c'est que a si même
il ya des gens qui le disent je crois
qu'on peut tout dire tu peux plus
aujourd'hui corps sauter les gens à
cause des réseaux sociaux à cause de
vous les gens super heureux de la
censure sur facebook oui mais la chine
est passée devant
encore était déjà derrière une pile en
tort non mais évidemment qui a je crois
qu'il ya soixante pays qui dans le monde
c'était sedan
et comment ça s'appelait ce truc là
reporters sans frontières ont le truc où
étaient ménard
c'était ça ces reporters sans frontières
il avait listé 60 pays qui
réduisent réduisait la liberté sur les
réseaux sociaux je sais pas si la france
en est parti je sais pas il question
internet qui est venu d'ailleurs très
tôt depuis hier soir pour les ultra fans
qui nous connaissent bien qui
connaissent les invités avant tout le
monde
donc il ya une question qui dit ici tu
sortais les mêmes vannes qu'à l'époque
tu seraient taxés d'islamophobie
islamophobes ou de sexiste
je sais pas on a été taxé d'antisémite
d'islamophobe
d'homophobe j'ai tout à l'heure au sujet
de d'amélie mauresmo
de gauchistes évidemment assez
régulièrement mais je pense que c'est
une une médaille pour les gens qui
faisaient le métier qu'on faisait d'être
insultée par tout le monde on a fait une
blague
on s'est fait traiter d'antisémite parce
que le jour de kippour le grand pardon
il ya de ça longtemps l'armée
israélienne avait tiré sur des gosses
palestinien et on avait tué trois ou
quatre et donc nous on avait fait une
lucarne avec un mec de l'armée
israélienne un billet avec costumes
armes et il a misé right here est pardon
pardon
ouais
antisémite
non je suis anti militaires israéliens
qui tuent des gosses ce jour de kippour
je suis pas antisémite mais amalgames et
puis ce qui nous voulait du mal nous
coller l'étiquette canton de cole
antisémites sur le don est mort
normalement tu peux plus aller nulle
part
islamophobe parce que on a été traités
d'islamophobe parce qu'un jour on a fait
lucarne aussi avec les mecs de comment
s'appelait le groupe
en algérie me souviens plus du nom d'un
groupe terroriste en algérie et on
disait il égorge tout ce qui est plus
intelligente que viendrait qui prenait
le gia il ya un mec qui prenaient une
poule et l'égorgé une poule
très vous êtes payés par les juifs
ok tant que les deux côtés tape ça va il
n'y a pas de problème
homophobes sur amélie mauresmo nom n'est
pas homophobe
sexiste
quand vous faites une femme
pour mettez des claques et christine
bravo
du sac avec bien-être romeo série golo
orbis puisqu'ils connaissent ça c'est ma
fille
c'est ma fille qui m'a dit qu'il a
trouvé ça avec les petits cailloux vendu
séparément lundi séparément pour la
lapider c'est ma fille me faudrait faire
une barbie spis découlent ainsi au
c'est drôle espèce d'icône as ça
vient d'eux
de ahmed hamidi qui était auteur son
père quand il voyait partir sa fille à
la voix lasse et que tu vas faire ton
espèce d'icône ans et je trouvais cette
expression vachement jolie spis du coin
et après on a collé ça mais tu vois pas
par exemple c'est un très bon exemple
suisse du queen's voilà un truc qu'on a
arrêté très vite parce que quand on fait
ben laden et mollah omar qui traite les
femmes disposent du coup la ce c'est
pour dire voilà comment ces deux
personnes et al-qaïda en général traite
femmes
et puis tu apprends que il ya des mecs
qui disent
aux nanas this piece du coulin c'est
qu'il commence à les maltraiter donc
nous on envoie un missile on perd le
guidage puisse a atterri n'importe où
donc on est responsable du premier tir
on n'est pas responsable de ce qu'ils
ont font fait on est responsable de ce
qu'on dit parce que les gens comprennent
la question d'internet on va monter un
peu le niveau là que pensez vous des
idées bourdieu sur le rapport audimat
médias contre information médias sur
médias alors je vais pas lui et cette
partie de bourdieu mais
je peux vous dire ce que je pense du
rapport média audimat
aujourd'hui le d'imad s'effondre
tf1 avait
40% de parts de marché il ya 20 ans ils
ont soit 1,20
la télévision est regardé par ma
génération car moi j'ai 60 ans
je crois que le service public c'est
au-dessus de 65 la moyenne d'âge des
gens qui regardent et il n'y a pas de en
masse de gens qui regardent la
télévision en dessous de 55 ans après il
ya quelques émissions hanoune a réussi à
taper sur le les 15-34
au prix de quoi au prix de quoi au prix
coin
d'une d'une façon de se comporter à
l'antenne qui doit correspondre à leur
public moi je peux pas juger de sas et
je suis pas la cible et je ne regarde
pas depuis des années je rien de plus et
je reviens pas ses émissions ça
m'apporte rien quand je regarde la
télévision je regarde planète je regarde
des fourmis insulter tout à l'heure je
préfère regarder des fourmis qui portent
des trucs lourd que que de regarder des
émissions de débats quand je veux
entendre des gens intelligents je
regarde je regarde vous charnière de
médias je regardais des trucs d'internet
sur des gens qui ont pris le temps 1h ou
1h30 pour expliquer quelque chose on
voit là et on est de plus en plus
l'ombre notamment des jeunes gens mon
fils regarde ça il est 19 ans le dernier
il fait ça passe le bonjour euh tu es
maintenant le garage peut-être pas
savoir je vais pas dire que je vais
annoncer ce matin sur twitter j'ai cru
que j'ai vu lisais je t'avais dit non
j'ai juste répondu à quelqu'un
c'est vachement bien ce que vous faisiez
j'ai dit oui en plus je le fais je t'es
fier
j'ai failli pulvérisé mais comprend pas
ce que j'aime pas c'est ça à paris mais
pulvérisé ou deux questions
est ce qu'il est intéressant de
continuer à payer sa taxe un texte de
redevance audiovisuelle
alors je crois qu'ils l'ont adossé à
autre chose donc du coup tu peux pas y
échapper
ce n'est le moi je pense que la dernière
aventure de télévision à mener c'est le
service public sur le service public on
devrait pouvoir faire une télévision
assez intéressante
bondé parce que plus de liberté parce
que plus de bruit parce que normalement
beaucoup de pognon une redevance c'est
que je ne sais pas combien ça rapporte
la drève redevance je sais que la grille
de canal coûté un milliard et demi
d'euros
à la grande époque un milliard trois
choix de coûts de grille donc il doit y
avoir un peu plus pour le service public
je pense
mais tu as surtout alors si je devais
m'occuper de ça je crois que je
supprimerai une chaîne quand même mail
laquelle ils vont supprimer francesco je
crois ils veulent essayer de m'en faire
une télé régionale mais je sais pas ils
sont encore en souffrance outre-mer
ouais je crois qu'ils veulent la
supprimer mais y'avait france 4 à une
époque qui servait à rien qu'ils ont un
peu doublon
mais peu importe on regrouperait les
gens vont venir personne c'est pas ça
l'idée mais ce serait intéressant
de voir comment un service public dirigé
par des délices curé des deux greffes
pourrait devenir quelque chose
d'intéressant et ringardiser les autres
télés j'en suis sûr mais pour ça il
faudrait que
soit nommé à la tête du service public
des gens qui
c'est à la tête du service public c'est
pas le présent de la république ah ouais
non ça se passera pas alors
mais là il nomme personne chez vous il
nomme personne sur internet pour
l'instant pour l'instant pour essayer
est ce que tu as déjà eu des procès oui
tu veux dire aux guignols ou guignols et
puis on passera après on ignore le mois
perd son nom j'en ai eu un legging dans
nos rues avec
comment s'appelle-t-elle oh là là je
connais kial normalement c'était criant
françoise sagan oui il y en a eu lundi
et mardi de france où un versus les
mardis de françoise ouais ouais bâle a
gagné sur cette attendue en fait elle a
gagné parce qu'elle aurait pu se servir
de cette dénomination pour une émission
elle mais elle a perdu sur tout le reste
et peugeot nous avaient attaqué
et le je crois que ça s'est terminé au
tribunal je suis pas allé mais notre
avocat a été génial il a dit quand
calvet qui était pdg de renault arrivé
plein de cambouis dans la lucarne en
disant j'ai eu un petit problème de
voiture il n'a jamais dit qu'il avait
une peugeot
donc les gens dit ben ouais m'enfin il
est pdg de peugeot oui
mais il n'a jamais dit je veux j'ai un
problème de voiture de la marque peugeot
edit j'ai un problème dans what sûrs
donc voilà donc on s'en est sorti comme
ça
personnellement à ce que tu as déjà reçu
des pressions est ce que
ta boite c'est un petit peu occupé de
des fadettes tu as lu des choses comme
ça oui mais ça c'est de notoriété
publique s'est matérialisé comment
par un procès
ça s'est matérialisé alors
si je refais est toute l'histoire je la
faire courte parce que l'instruction a
duré cinq ans en 2002
des gens dont canal+ que je peux citer
parce qu'ils ont été condamnés dont
gilles klein et borelli j'oubliais son
prénom
m'ont écouté mon téléphone on trianguler
on téléphone comment alors la
triangulation il faut demander
aux services en fait de de me suivre à
la trace par mon téléphone alors pour ça
il y a une technique comme vous recevez
beaucoup des gens des services ici ça se
trouve vous êtes des services secrets
on vous a collé ça on vous la dire
franchement ils feraient mieux mais je
disais
donc
il faut pour que les flics puisse
trianguler un téléphone qu'il y ait une
commission rogatoire il faut qu'un juge
disent oui vous pouvez le faire pour
qu'un juge puisse le faire il faut le
manipuler ou qu'ils aient de bonnes
raisons mais moi n'y avait pas de bonnes
raisons donc pour le manipuler
à l'époque je sais pas comment ça se
passe maintenant on prend une puce de
téléphone qu'on appelle une puce blanche
et on peut attribuer à cette puce
blanche n'importe quel numéro donc on
prend un numéro 10 l'heure et on appelle
avec ce numéro ma pomme et pendant un
mois à peu près j'ai eu un mec qui
m'appelait qui disais allô david villa
non c'est pas david
hava vous êtes qui
c'est vous qui m'appelait dites moi
plutôt vous qui vous êtes on va gagner
du temps d'andré c'est juste chercher
david c'est une erreur au revoir
monsieur
deux jours après le même et tout ça
pendant un mois une dizaine ou une
douzaine de coups de fil ensuite les
flics vont voir un juge en lui disant le
numéro de téléphone du dealer là qu'on
connaît bien il a appelé dix fois bruno
gaccio à canal à mon avis il ya quelque
chose il faudrait qu'on le surveille et
le juge que ce qu'ils fassent ils à sa
cause un faux et du malaisie
sauf que pour écouter quelqu'un il faut
je crois si flic à peu près 6 avec il
coûte le matin d'autres la nuit d'autres
qui vont faire des pauses café enfin il
ya des gens ça mobilise des gens donc ça
coûte de l'argent
et au bout de deux ou trois jours il ya
un des flics qui a dit
on n'a pas le bon téléphone ou alors on
est en train de monter un turbin sur
gaccio parce que il va de canala chez
lui de chez lui à canal temps en temps
restaurants un cinéma il fait rien et
ils n'appellent pas le dealer lui et le
dealer marrant il l'appelle plus donc on
est en train de faire quoi là et ça
s'est arrêté net
il ya plus
ça ça se passe en 2002 en
2005 ou 2006 2005 peut-être
sera livre qui s'appelle un agent sort
de l'ombre un ancien de la dgse
service action
il s'appelle pierre martinet
qui écrit ce livre dans lequel il y à
une vingtaine une trentaine de pages sur
moi et sur ce qu'on lui a demandé de
faire à canal contre -
et l'éditeur de ce livre s'appelle guy
birenbaum vient me voir et me dit voilà
j'ai une bombe qui va sortir tu es
dedans
tu veux lire avant
j'aimerais bien oui parce que j'aurais
bien savoir et il me dit là il me dit ça
lui mais ça a pas été évoquée dans le
procès directement
ils ont essayé de te tuer
mon pardon j'étais à rtl il y avait mon
fils qui jouait on a une émission et
monfils 6 n'écoute pas toi comment ça
ils ont essayé de te tuer il ya un
dossier aux maux qui a été montée contre
toi quoi c'est débile je comprends pas
ils me donnent le dossier au mot il me
donne tous les éléments et me dit si tu
veux tu peux rencontrer pierre martinage
dit oui je le fais venir chez moi je lui
dis on sera jamais copains il
connaissait la maison était déjà né de
chez toi il y avait fait des photos des
serrures il avait fait une connaissait
la maison et je viens on sera jamais
copains explique moi pourquoi t'as fait
ça il me dit pour protéger
à hindi voilà tous les éléments que tu
as en main qu'on va te donner
tu pourras aller donner un juge si tu
portes plainte ils sont tous étayé
c'est à dire que j'ai tout fait à
l'envers à la dgse nous a appris des
choses j'ai tout fait à l'envers chaque
fois que j'étais quelque part je
téléphonais chaque fois j'avais quelque
chose à payer je payais avec mon ma
carte de crédit chaque fois que j'allais
quelque part je parlais à des gens je
suis pas passée inaperçue nulle part les
caméras de surveillance il faisait
toutes prises
donc maintenant
c'est ainsi dans tes mains tu fais ce
que tu veux donc j'ai pris la nuit pour
réfléchir et j'ai dit c'est pas normal
qu'on fasse ça à quelqu'un qui ne fait
que écrire
je suis pas
un homme d'affaires je possède aucun
secret de fabrication de canal plus je
connaissais rien à rien j'étais pas dans
les boucles de deux décodeurs pire à
toute chose comme ça j'étais dedans rien
juste j'écrivais une émission quand même
un peu dans comment ça je te donne deux
exemples d'accords le pro vie tu
t'attaques est la propagande de guerre
américaine ouais oraux
ou tu t'attaques à la propagande de
guerre américaine tu les fais passer
pour des demeurés
qui
sont pas très mince et jean yves
coudriou moussaoui ils ont une puissance
énorme ils ont beaucoup de pognon mais
ils sont pas très mince il mettait
autant d'énergie à être malin leur pays
leurs peuples seraient bien plus heureux
il préfère faire des conneries pour
aller chercher du pétrole
on n'ira qu'en inventant des histoires
avec l'autre la colline powell l être
éclate dans bastille en amène le pas
crétin si tu fais tomber la fiole on va
tous mourir donc c'était forcément faux
pompe à ce type de risque j'ai de
l'anthrax et étaient débiles qu'on peut
croire les gens ont cru il ya des
américains qui croyait très sérieusement
que les irakiens avait des missiles
capables d'aller taper new york
tu t'attaques à la propagande de guerre
tue le temps est plus très bien voir la
cia rigole parce que tu empêches la
france de rentrer en guerre à leurs
côtés donc un bon s'éteint jamais
traversé l'esprit saint en
île à l est sur le coup de canal+
c'était pourquoi
c'est parce que lescure avait été viré
par jean marie messier que c'était une
erreur stratégique en dehors du fait
qu'il avait peut-être des bisbilles
entre eux que je connais pas mais
c'était une erreur stratégique tu vires
pas lescure de canal en mettant à la
place des ateliers couture qui est
numéro 3 à l'époque de tf1 c'est juste
impossible tu dis aux 3000 personnes qui
bossent à canal vous êtes de la merde
c'est ça qui nous disaient vous n'êtes
rien vous ne valez pas mieux qu'en face
alors que nous on se construisait
contre aussi cette façon de faire de la
télé qu'avait tf1 c'est ça l'esprit
canal
alors de grève disait cd l'esprit canal
c'est des ronds dans des carrés il faut
faire rentrer des spermes ans d'écart et
la presse disant est génial faut-il
pourquoi tu as dis ça c'est pas ça fait
peur mais l'esprit canal c'est juste des
gens qui est avais pas envie de trop
prendre le public pour des cons même si
audi gnole parfois on a fait des
émissions tout pourri parce qu'on
n'avait pas d'idées donc on faisait des
émissions tout pourri on avait honte on
disait ah là là mon dieu ce soir quelle
horreur je me souviens d'un truc c'était
honteux dans tous les sens du terme la
vanne étaient honteuses et
l'inflammation traité était honteuse
c'est des moines de tibérine qui se
souvient de ces histoires qui seront
égorgés par le gia truc atroce et ont
fait un hommage ces moines par jacques
toubon qui dit jeu
c'était des moines trappistes et il dit
je vois là je voulais rendre hommage à
tous ces moines trapézistes et plus
généralement à toute la famille du
cirque les clowns bien sûr et on part
sur les moines trapéziste quoi c'est
honteux les mecs viennent d'être égorgé
nous fait ça le public les jambes drôle
le quittant la salle région grigol et
nous n'avez honte dit merde on a fait
une bonne pub pour y
en trente ans après je peux lire moi il
m'a fait marrer le dossier d'exécution
c'était beaucoup alors oui alors pour
finir
donc je vais
porter plainte contre x l'ama direction
me convoque bertrand méheut et il me dit
pourquoi ont porté plainte contre x
c'est pierre martinet qui gémit lui il
accuse deux autres personnes et je veux
que les enquêtes soient le plus large
possible dit ouais mais là vous allez
attaquer canal + moi c'est pas possible
sinon j'attends que jamais j'attaquerai
canal+ c'est ma maison je suis et même
aujourd'hui alors que c'est devenu un
truc que je regarde plus je n'attaquerai
jamais canal+ parce que ça m'a construit
socialement financièrement voire même
sexuellement parce que j'y ai rencontré
la mère de mon dernier au fond donc ça
me fait une famille donc je veux pas
attaquer cette chaîne je dis simplement
il ya des gens à l'intérieur de cette
chaîne dans un moment où le pouvoir
était flottants ont fait un certain
nombre de choses inégales et
répréhensibles et je voudrais savoir qui
les a fait ces choses c'est pour ça que
je porte plainte contre x il a compris
l'instruction a duré cinq ans et je me
suis aperçu que donc j'avais ce dossier
homo mais qu'on pouvait pas s'en servir
parce qu'il ya pas eu début d'exécution
j'avais toujours un dossier chez moi je
le garde dans un truc je le regarde bien
c'est maintenant je sais comment on
organise l'assassinât quelqu'un à la
dgse enfin en tout cas un mec comme moi
après il en suffit pas non jamais par le
service action ça sert pas à ça
mais quand je dis pourquoi ils vont
taper avec un manche de pioche à
martinez mais pourquoi on me tuerait
avec un manche de pioche et pourquoi pas
une balle dans la tête il dit parce que
une balle dans la tête c'est du grand
banditisme c'est pas crédible pour toi
t'es pas cap' ali au grand banditisme et
en les gens vont dire il ya un truc qui
va pas on pourrait faire sauter sa
voiture aussi mettre une bombe dans ta
voiture pendant qu'on y est mais ça n'a
aucun sens alors que le manche de pioche
tu travailles dans la restauration là ça
peut être un concurrent ça peut être un
fournisseur t'as pas payer ça peut être
un mari qui pensent qu'il est trompé et
kitty jaloux ici tu tapes ça peut être
une bagarre idiote ya plein de trucs
donc c'est crédible voilà pourquoi le
binôme qui doit se farcir la tête le
fera aux manches de pioche enfin devait
le faire on mange de pièges et il n'y a
pas eu début d'exécution donc quand je
suis allé devant la première juge
d'instruction si on a eu deux trois je
crois
elle me dit mais on pourra pas retenir
ce truc là parce que un début
d'exécution ça veut dire que quelqu'un
aurait loué une voiture dans la région
pour faire une action c'est ça un début
d'exécution là il n'y a même pas eu ça
parce qu'ils ont reculé en voyant
l'ampleur de ce qu'ils avaient fait
martinez je crois est toujours pour me
protéger le martinet et
la juge me dit par contre ça éclaire
toute la folie du reste ce truc là ça
est clair qu'on vous suive sa est clair
qu'on vous espionne chez vous il ya des
photos de ma baby sitter de l'époque il
devait bien l'aimer parce qu'il ya sur
25 photos qui sont dans le dossier il y
en a douze de la baby sitter en maillot
de bain avec les gosses meurent
et surtout alors ça aussi ça arrivait au
tribunal parce que les gens disaient
mais pour se défend disais mais pourquoi
on aurait fait ça c'est une histoire de
cornecul si on voulait se débarrasser de
lui dont le veer est c'est tout pourquoi
on aurait fait ça et à l'époque
2002 j'ai pris
ardisson avait dit la tête d'une révolte
c'était pas du tout une révolte c'est du
pur syndicalisme
j'avais monté une asso
et
on luttait contre messier et ça faisait
baisser le cours de l'action
et s'il ya une chose qui est
inacceptable
plus que se foutent de la gueule d'un
politiques se foutent de la gueule du
pdg être homophobe être antisémite être
islamophobe faire baisser le cours d'une
action ça c'est inacceptable laisse pas
passer jamais on perd beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'oseille donc la non arrêtez
moi ce qu'on l'a
après qui donne l'ordre initial j'en
sais rien
question sur question d'internet c'est
un poisson je fais chier tout le monde
non non que pense-t-il de la déchéance
de canal+ aux dérogations est-ce que
canal plus et en déchéance alors comme
je viens de vous le dire je ne regarde
plus
je me suis désabonné et
il ya une stratégie qui différente de
celle qui était avant la stratégie
d'avant c'était d'aller taper dans des
niches c'est à dire qu'on avait des
choses avec lesquelles j'étais pas
d'accord à canal mois la corrida j'ai
toujours été contre mais il ya cent
mille personnes qui s'adonnaient pour ça
donc il y avait cette histoire de niche
le monde audiovisuel a changé et
aujourd'hui j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y
avait une sorte de rapprochement avec
netflix pour que canal et netflix soit
une sorte de plateforme de distribution
de deux films de séries d'émissions je
sais pas
j'espère que ça va générer beaucoup
d'abonnés parce que comme je le disais
tout à l'heure il faudrait que votre
communauté vérifie mais le coût de
grille de canal de la deûle époque où j
étais c'était un milliard trois pour
faire rentrer 1,1 milliard 3 faut quand
même qu'ils aient pas mal d'abonnés si
on perd des abonnés ou si on a des
abonnés à 2 euros on ne peut pas
fabriquer des émissions des séries et
une grille donc il faut faire des choix
quels sont les choix stratégiques
d'aujourd'hui je n'en ai pas la moindre
idée franchement je sais pas du tout où
ils vont pourtant la meilleure chaîne de
télé à l'heure actuelle c'est quoi
aujourd'hui sur le service français
arte hier soir il y avait une excellente
thema sûr il y avait lordon à la télé
hier soir mais qui va jamais à la télé
lors dont il était arte il y avait david
grimbert il y avait quelques quelques
paquets d'économistes qui parlait de
salaire de chômage de revenu à vis de
plein de choses comme ça et
c'était intéressant et je faisais du
baby-sitting hier soir je gardais mes
petits enfants car je suis grand père
et je l'avais leçon très bas puis ma
fille rentre et j'ai pas vu la fin de
l'émission donc je vais me taper le
replay et oui c'est une bonne télévision
la pire tuerie
la pire
l'ensemble nous tous les ans on a pire
telle est la pire télévision c'est celle
qui n'a pas comme objectif
d'informer et de divertir ou d'éduquer
qu'en aucun moment
les dirigeants d'une chaîne se disent on
va alors divertir cia mort mais ça s'est
sèchement ce qui en fait c'est faire
diversion voilà c'est de
divertir à la télé c'est assez simple et
c'est un cercle vicieux plus ont
divertis avec des choses médiocre plus
les gens s'habituent à des choses
médiocre et plus on peut leur fils ait
des choses médiocre mais à la fin tout
ça
ces gens là sont censés voter
pour les gens qui vont les représenter
et là tu es dans la catastrophe complète
quoi tu dis mais le film idiocracy que
tu as tu as vu ce truc là
j'étais passé à côté du film à sa sortie
en 2006 suis passé complètement à côté
je pars yards et je les regardais sur
netflix
c'est un film
que je pense j'aurai je leur ai zappé en
2006 parce qu'il était mal fait très con
mal filmé
mais ce qu'il porte est-ce qu'il
contient
c'est la société qu'on est en train de
vivre aujourd'hui c'est une idiot cratie
le président des états unis est élu dans
ce film parce qu'il a tapé un autre mec
dans une bagarre dont 20 octogone il a
gagné il et mastoc comme ça ils tirent à
la sulfateuse les avocats sont débiles
tout est débile et le monde dirigé par
des débiles va jusqu'à
mettre du soda pour arroser les plantes
et il se demande pourquoi ça pousse pas
et il faut qu'il ya un mec qui arrive du
passé qui a été cryogénisé qui se
réveille pour leur dire fois mettre de
l'eau
genre 10 mais non l'eau c'est pour les
chiottes et on est dans un monde comme
ça aujourd'hui on te dit mais non le
marché sa réguler y'a que ça dans les
dents régime et les gens qui te dit ça
c'est pas tous des économistes ou des
margoulins qui veulent perpétuer comme
ça c'est de pensée unique c'est des gens
qui
sont à des salaires normaux quoi enfin
qui gagnent bien leur vie qui disons
mais c'est très bien non il n'y a que
comme ça que ça marche chez seat et
communistes du même nom mais entre les
deux il ya des trucs comme elle est la
réflexion au nom question d'internet
de crapule of the do les grands médias
se positionne très souvent voire
systématiquement comme des juges
idéologique et moraux exemple pour ou
contre cautionner ceci ou condamnés cela
au détriment d'une quelconque réflexion
intellectuelle each considérer l'état
que nouvelle idole les médias ne
serait-il pas devenus les porte voix
d'une idée de l'idéologie qui se serait
radicalisé point d'interrogation alors
les médias sont devenu l'idole
et tous les médias y compris internet
c'est eux les idoles
les médias en fait ce qui nous dit c est
ce qu ils sont les porte paroles
d'un état d'un
nom même plus besoin on n'a pas toute
votre communauté et au courant que neuf
milliardaire ont acheté les médias ils
n'ont pas acheté pour faire de l'argent
puisque dans un média on perd de
l'argent ils les ont achetés pour avoir
une influence philanthrope c'est ce que
je pense aussi pour en connaître deux ou
trois noms mais donc ils ne font pas
pour ça ils le font pour imaginer une
influence qui décline elle décline cette
influence par contre ils ont réussi à
fabriquer un président de la république
ils ont fabriqué très bien ok ça a
marché une fois savard marché une autre
fois
je vous ai dit qu'il est très lu un mois
je pense qu'il va être réélu oui parce
qu'ils vont faire en sorte que face à un
jeu très très dangereux parce que fly et
les deux grands partis d'opposition ou
de gouvernement
samassi i ez en mai il était parti en
sucette depuis très longtemps mais qu'un
parti socialiste qui se dit de gauche et
qui met manuel valls comme premier
ministre juste envie de te tire une
balle dans la tête bon ça n'existe pas
normalement mais parti socialiste en
fait maintenant ils sont juste parti
n'existe plus mais les flingues et c'est
bien ça m'a fait marrer fillon ça m'a
fait marrer sauf qu'à la place tu mets
quoi y'a plus rien maintenant entre
l'hyper centre là le cette espèce de de
conglomérat d'intérêts même pas comment
qui en train de partir en sucette là sur
la pma et tout ça ça part en sucette
complète évolutive ou sur le voile sur
leurs e mails voile c'est une diversion
utiliser ça
à chaque fois
fillon n'avait déjà fait valls l'a fait
bah ils le font hop en voile et les
arabes un grand remplacement j'ai dix
ans un jour je me suis fait tuer sur
twitter il il ya des tweets qui sont des
détecteurs à connard sont magnifiques et
j'ai dit si le grand emplacement si
c'est pour remplacer zemmour goldnadel
toute la bande là je vais pouvoir aux
l'âge est là sans réponse tu te fais
incendiés et donc tu bloques cette
région pour les inviter zemmour ici ça
ça 3 yards moi je suis pour la liberté
d'expression
j'ai écrit un bouquin enfin j'ai
participé à un bouquin et dieudonné on a
suffisamment reproché est principalement
des gens qui n'ont pas lu et je les
relis il ya trois jours je vais publier
ma partie
là je sais pas où sur réseau peut-être
que vous avez un truc un truc écrit vous
n'aurez pas ça oui le publierai chez
vous parce que je vous aime bien je veux
publier ma partie parce que j'ai pas un
mot à retirer de ce que j'ai dit et la
liberté d'expression c'est ce que je dis
on ce truc là ça consiste pas être
d'accord avec le mec qui tu parles la
liberté d'expression ça consiste à
laisser la parole à des gens qui ont une
pensée y compris aberrante simplement en
face il faut mettre en matériel critique
je me suis frites et une fois au flore
intellectuelle du floor
avec faurisson que je connaissais pas je
n'aime pas la tête qu'il allait
c'était il ya une dizaine une douzaine
d'années
j'avais écrit un bouquin avec philippe
bilger qui s'appelait le guignol elle
magistrats et dans lequel on parlait de
liberté d'expression et je disais
la liberté d'expression est totale mais
est tout et non le mais on a tous un
mais on est d'accord pour laisser parler
tout le monde mais pas lui pas elle pas
et faurisson que je connaissais pas donc
un jour un petit bonhomme qui arrive
dans six chapeaux et d'initiation je
vous connais j'ai lu votre livre merci
c'est très gentil me tend la main je lui
serre la main
il dit vous dites que donc la liberté
d'expression est totale mais tout est
dans le vin quel est le vôtre
le mien c'est la souffrance
dans le travail que je fais aux guignols
si on blesse quelqu'un qu'il est à terre
et qu'il souffre vaut mieux s'arrêter ça
sert à rien c'est voilà c'est ma limite
c'est la souffrance à l'autre est ce
qu'on apporte du bien ou est ce qu'on
apporte du mal si on apporte du mal vaut
mieux qu'on s'arrête ma liberté
d'expression c'est aussi de ne pas
m'exprimer si je veux je me tais a
indian moi j'ai subi dix attaques
physiques les gens m'ont interdit de
parler et je me présente je m'appelle
robert faurisson
tu dis tu as eu dix attaques physiques
ouais j'ai dit alors tu te barres parce
que la 11e et l'easa du coin qu'il faut
de barre toi ignorait pourquoi j'ai pas
le droit de dire ce que j'ai à dire je
dis non non c'est pas ça
ce que tu avais à dire sur les chambres
à gaz tu as écrit une thèse elle a été
publiée elle a été démontée tu as voulu
la soutenir ils ont démonté ta thèse de
la tête aux pieds
et toi depuis trente ans tu continues
tu as une maladie mec était obsédé tu as
une obsession avec les juifs pas une
obsession donc tu me parles pas et tu
dégages
et là je veux m'asseoir à la table est
qui et j'étais avec jean je comprends il
était ministre
déporté ministre de l'
ex ministre de la culture espagnole un
mec formidable copains de lescure ce
comme ça je l'avais rencontrée et m'a
dit c'est qu'il vieux
tu tu avais l'air pas contents qu'ils
essaient robert faurisson et mon regard
différent est encore vivant cette merde
et la discussion s'est arrêté là on en a
plus parlé donc
faurisson il a le droit de faire ce
qu'il avait envie de faire il a écrit ce
qu'ils voulaient ça a été démontée
normalement après tu t'arrêtes tu
essayes encore une fois ou deux histoire
dira ils ont tort mais après tu arrêtes
tu passe à autre chose quand tu passes
pas autre chose c'est qu'il ya un
problème
zemmour invite lâchement fou poser les
bonnes questions il va trouver dans la
farine parce qu'il est très fort mais
posez les prix dotés des riens qui fait
que cech bien sûr mais il pour moi il a
le droit de s'exprimer après c'est
combien de temps il s'exprime à la place
de qui s'expriment qu'ils en fassent
si tu lui donnes libres parole sans
contradiction alors tu fais une faute
parce que ce qu'il véhicule est quelque
chose de mortifère à la fin il ya des
gens qui peuvent se faire tuer donc il a
le droit de dire ce qu'il a à dire je
veux pas l'empêcher de parler
j'empêcherai jamais personne de parler
mais en face faute ya une contradiction
si moi je lui porter la contradiction je
me ferais rouler parce que sur ces
sujets là qui ne m'ont jamais intéressé
à une
des gens avec des voiles des jeans des
nike des sites et j'en ai rien à
en fait dans la rue ils font ce qu'ils
veulent ils ont droit de s'habiller
comme ils veulent moi je veux pas qu'on
me dise comment je dois m'habiller donc
ils font ce qu'ils veulent je veux juste
que ce soit consentie quand une femme se
voile ou mais un foulard parce que ya
aussi des différences entre la burqa le
grillage et le foulard il ya des
différences
toutes les femmes n'ont pas de sa porte
sur combien de clients en gros que la
doudoune à intégral on n'en sait rien je
sais pas moi donc
cette obsession là
elle vient de gens à mon avis qu'ils
sont un peu dérangé ou qui ont trouvé
une combine
pourquoi le pognon c'est par des marchés
oui oui mais ça buzze zemmour c'est très
clair il écrit des livres personnes les
lits et puis un jour il écrit un truc
sur les femmes en disant qu'elles ont
pris le pouvoir que les hommes songe pas
à quoi
ils ont été enfin féminisé quoiqu'il ya
plus d'hommes tout d'un coup ça se vend
bien après midi après les et les femmes
alors elles ont été soumises après les
l'islam et lutte face à ce vent bon il
ya une clientèle pour ça il continue il
va pas s'arrêter
question d'internet
est ce que dans ton job quel genre de
soucis apporte son soutien au gilet
jaune
alors aujourd'hui aucun aucun si ce
n'est que
mes amis du bas jamais eu d'amis dans le
show business mais mes relations au
show-business mme pas il parle plus mais
dans mon job moi j'ai plus de jobs
d'avoir chez chômeurs je joue au théâtre
une pièce s'appelle les pâtes à l'ail
c'est le théâtre vachement bien parce
que c'est directement entre toiles
public donc le seul filtre qui pourrait
y avoir c'est le patron de la salle
et du montet et bolloré h est plein de
salles de théâtre car il ya des lyonnais
qui te demandes comment on fait qu'il
secret pour réussir des pâtes à l'ail
les faire la halle dente dedans mettre
beaucoup d'amour
certains le connais pas taillé
un vieux pote qui on voit son vieux pote
pas très bien qui fait des pâtes away
donc tu avais vraiment pas préparé
l'émission point cette fois tu as
vraiment ailleurs préparés lutte
les pâtes à l'ail ça parle de la mort ça
parle du cancer et ça parle de jusqu'où
on peut aller par amitié pour quelqu'un
est ce que on peut aller jusqu'à
détruire une amitié pour maintenir
l'autre en vie ce qui a une preuve
d'amitié mais l'amitié détruites c'est
de ça que ça traite
en face de cette situation réellement
des soins palliatifs ça parle des choses
comme ça oui
oui j'ai été
quand mon père
a été diagnostiqué un cancer des poumons
80% des deux poumons prix
on savait qu'il n'avait plus pour six
mois
lui était dans une sorte de de dénis
l'amiante la clope ils avaient arrêté
depuis 30 ans mais lui laisser l'amiante
il a passé sa vie dans la maçonnerie à
monter et démonter des usines et des
machins qui avait de l'amiante partout
les ombelles il avait des combi en
amiante et truc il a baigné dans
l'amiante les morts poumon amiante et
donc on savait que c'était fini
comme on n'est pas croyant dans la
famille dieu nous parle très peu
on s'est mis à jour
on a parlé
de mes grands parents
de ma grand mère paternelle de sa mère
dont je pensais qu'elle était sicilienne
qui met toute ma vie j'ai pensé qu'elle
était née à caltanissetta et qu'elle
avait vécu à cordes l'hérault n'est pas
ce qui m'a pas elle a vécu là bas je
pensais qu'elle était de là bas et à mon
père julie mais qu'en même temps albi
nom n'a jamais vraiment parler d'elle
edit il m'a jamais demandé arrêt 2c vrai
n 10 mais on sait pas où elle est née ah
bon
zynga là c'était une cigale dit ça se
trouve elle est né en yougoslavie on
sait pas l'âge qu'elle a on n'a jamais
su a
donc c'était en 2007
sale année 2007 un sarkozy qui arrive
mon père qui part of et un
en 2007 j'apprends que ma grand mère
paternelle
est une cigale
c'est bizarre quand même
moi j'adore la guitare manouche me suis
dit c'est pas possible cependant
les gêne ça n'existe pas voilà donc mon
père je savais que c'était fini on s'est
mis à jour là dessus et puis
les quinze derniers jours
il était en souffrance complète il avait
perdu du poids énormément il est aigri
et
je suis allé voir là
[Musique]
le patron de l'hôpital non je n'ai pas
vu j'ai vu la patronne de l'hosto aux
fumées qui se dirigeait un service en
tout cas et je lui dis il faut arrêter
de faire souffrir si là il a très mal et
plus que lui ma mère est en souffrance
complète
il faudrait arrêter ce à quoi elle a une
dizaine héros ont fait pas d'euthanasie
monsieur gilles vous parle pas de ça
je vous parle de coma
dans le serment d'hippocrate vous devez
mettre fin aux souffrances donc là le
moyen d'arrêter ses souffrances et de le
mettre dans un coma profond parce que là
il est vraiment ils sont froids tape
comme sont l'île et il a des douleurs
incroyable plus rien la mort finit fait
plus rien à faire
et on a discuté une bonne heure
je pense qu'ils ont monté ce thé pour
savoir si
j'étais
fragile
inconscient de ce que je demandais
et au bout d'une heure ils m'ont dit on
va le faire donc ils m'ont envoyé une
infirmière
que je connaissais pas elle a installé
une espèce de d'appareils vert comme ça
dans le ciel mon maire une seringue et
de la morphine
je sais pas ce que c'est exactement mais
elle a simplement poussé le truc comme
ça elle a dit voilà jusque là c'est le
commun au delà c'est létale elle est
partie
jusque 1 jusque comment
les soins palliatifs c'est pas du tout
abordé en france i win on est ce que je
sais pas la loi léonetti dit qu'on
maintenant on a droit à la sédation
profonde mais c'est les médecins qui
choisissent et moi je suis membre de la
dmd l'association pour le droit à mourir
dans la dignité et
j'aimerais que ce soit le
patient le malade qui choisissent moi
j'aimerais
partir comme ça cette traite de st dans
la pièce on l'a dit c'est marrant il ya
une interview qui est sorti aujourd'hui
et un papier qu'on a fait folie théâtre
sur la pièce on dit ça et clients ricoh
et qui joue la pièce
dis moi j'aimerais qu'il le fasse si ça
m'arrivait
est bon
et j'aimerais moi que ça se passe comme
ça moi je suis pour choisir le moment
auquel je parle plus tard possible je
suis bien d'accord même malade je vais
faire tout ce qu'il faut pour m'en
sortir mais le jour où je saurai
parce que je le saurai je suis informé
quand même que ces morts que c'est fini
je voudrais pouvoir réunir ma famille
les gens que j'aime bien et leur dire
voilà
j'aimerais qu'on se dise au revoir si
vous avez des choses à me dire que vous
n'avez pas dit ou entendre que je vous
ai pas dit j'aimerais qu'on le fasse
maintenant parce que une fois que vous
serez sortie de la pièce moi je vais
partir vous allez rentrer chez vous moi
je vais rentrer chez moi
et on se reverra plus j'aimerais qu'on
parte sur un bon moment où je suis
encore où je me ressemble encore une
façon nourrie en vivant
question d'internet ce que vous
connaissez les directives anticipées
les directives anticipées non ça parle
de quoi aucune idée
je pensais qu'il me ferait chier avec
dieudonné où ça va pourquoi tu pourquoi
te faire chier parce que généralement on
me fait chier et dieudonné sur internet
de leurs bombes
au nom mais je sais bien je suis en
bonnes mains généralement on me dit les
gens qui n'ont pas lu le livre d'isaïe
l'a écrit un bouquin et dieudonné est
antisémite
non mais je jeu merci + 2 sketch de
dieudonné bon en tout et pour tout temps
a vu deux de ses spectacles c'est
marrant oui bah ouais c'est vraiment pas
pourquoi parce que ces marrons c'est
difficile à dire c'est le meilleur de
tous les deux tous les humoristes
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il est
d'ailleurs on parlait de liberté
d'expression y avoir un truc
voilà le seul humoriste français
à qui on a pitié son théâtre et à qui on
interdit de jouer dans des salles il n'a
pas le droit de jouer donc il a acheté
un bus s'ils jouent dans le bus
il dit c'est juste qu'ils condamnent n'y
a pas de choses aussi il a été condamné
ouais je croirais pour antisémitisme
bois appels à la haine raciale zemmour
aussi un nom lui a donné une émission en
limo
donc il joue aussi chez des particuliers
ce qui dit il parce qu'il a des fans
mais en pagaille et il dit aux gens je
joue à rouen par exemple bon nombre à
rouen dans quelle salle il dit rien les
gens achètent leurs billets et deux
heures avant ils disent et atteindrait
ce à tel endroit donc avant que les
flics arrivent lui il a monté une petite
scène hop hop hop il fait sa petite
affaire
mais c'est quand même le seul mec qui
est interdit et ça veut pas dire ce que
je dis là ça veut pas dire que je
soutiens ce qu'il dit
quand il parle des juifs et de
l'antisémitisme ça veut pas dire que je
soutient ça ça veut dire que je fais le
constat que
dieudonné en france n'a plus le droit de
jouer
et il est marrant parcours il a
influencé toute une génération
d'humoristes
incroyablement les nouvelles pointures
de
l'humoriste si on peut dire ça comme ça
à la ségolène royal
c'est quoi c'est l'une des plus marc
antoine ségolène cdm arctique avec les
pingouins jamais vu alors quand elle
fait des voyages en jet privé ministre
départ est moins salée l'ordre quand
même les nouveaux humoristes qui vont
bien c'est cool
en ce moment
il ya blanche gardin qui continue à me
faire mourir de rire et éboué dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
il ya
guillaume meurice dans une moindre
mesure mais c'est plus de la de la radio
et de la télé mais il a trouvé un truc
qu'il a trouvé un style une façon de
questionner très intéressante et
amusante
un mec qui s'appelle jim o
c'est un mec qui est lent il est super
lent alors que le stand up c'est bonjour
ça va lui il arrive il est lent là on va
recevoir un humoriste suisse un petit
gamin qui fait des sketches justin rose
du comité de direction de nestlé ou
danone ah ouais ouais je me rappelle
plus de 100 je vais le retrouver aussi
parce que je vois qui tu parles très
sympa ouais ouais ouais il est très bon
les baiia marina aussi comment elle
s'appelle marina
banderas une suisse aussi je crois il ya
une tic idi fait le chiac pierre carles
alors qui s'y passe et des pires car
avec pierre carles or rien de spécial
avec pierre car il a fait un
documentaire
sur canal mais pierre carles à une
méthode moi qui me fait plutôt marrer
c'est qu'ils piègent les gens c'est là
que i tonm interview tu le micro moi je
lai le micro je sais que je suis écouté
quand je parle mais il ya des gens qui
savent pas qu'ils sont écoutés quand il
parlait pierre carles faisait ça souvent
et il avait piégé de greffe il avait
piégé je sais plus qui ils avaient dit
des choses terribles mais non je n'ai
pas de problème avec pierre carles moi
pourquoi question internet s'ils ne
regarde plus la télé il s'informe
comment la lecture mme sur la lecture
enfin ça dépend comment je m'en informe
thomas vizille nous c'est tout mais rien
n'est joué ouais il est très bon il est
très très bon
comment je m'en informe alors le matin
quand je me lève je regarde twitter je
vois les articles qui sont qui sortent
et je vais lire ces articles là
pour les informations télévisées la
dernière fois que j'ai regardé c'est
hier j'ai zappé pendant 20 minutes sur
les chaînes d'info pour voir comment ils
traitaient les crs qui tape les pompiers
j'ai déjà lu me coucher j'ai dit stop on
arrête tout ça sert à rien je recrute
parenthèses les directives anticipées
toute personne majeure peut si elle le
souhaite faire une déclaration écrite ap
les directives anticipées pour préciser
ses souhaits concernant sa fin de vie et
je vous laisserai regarder la suite sur
internet merci d'avancé à remonter ça
oui à la communauté et à dire que alors
tu as le droit de demander à ce qu'ils
arrêtent de thalie menthe et de te
de ty raté je crois que c'est ça la loi
léonetti c'est ça en fait c'est qu'ils
te met dans un coma profond donc tu ne
souffrent plus et après les médecins
décident avec la famille ou je ne sais
comment d'arrêter ton alimentation et l
hydratation de faillite le laisse mourir
de faim et de soif alors qu'il suffirait
qui t'envoie un coup de morphine on n'en
parle plus mais bon je sais pas pourquoi
il ya tout un tout un aspect moral et
religieux derrière
il ya vraiment ça il ya vraiment il n'ya
que dieu qui peut choisir le moment où
ça s'arrête on si nous c nous arrive nos
directives anticipées c'est vous nous
poussez de la fais
sans parachute ont saisi ça tu arrives
ici je te plus du ballet non non non pas
du bacon si ça m'arrive ici tu m'en veux
juste au mont d'or c'est très joli il te
balance et ouais avec le sourire oh
moi je suis pour la liberté totale donc
et si ça marche pas en arrivant qu'une
fille dans la rue là on parle de meurtre
admira non là je ne peux pas de finir je
te finit pas bon d'ailleurs même de
pousser c'est un meurtre alors oui
exactement
je le ferai pas est ce que tu vois des
choses arrêt abordé avec nous un bandit
ou tu veut creuser
l'émission d'hier m'a fait me faire
rappeler que j'avais et je travaillais
sur un sujet qui était le bonus
universel
vous avez reçu frio et c'est oui bernard
bernard friot l'avait reçue coutume à
hawaï énorme bernard friot sur le
salaire à vie et je suis fan du salaire
à vie bien évidemment mais c'est un
aboutissement entre temps il faut des
étapes et j'avais travaillé sur un bonus
universel
dans une monnaie virtuelle pas des
histoires de bitcoin blocs chine inde
est vraiment une monnaie virtuelle qui
n'existent pas qu'on appellerait le
bonus
il ne serait pas matérialisées donc par
des billets ou des pièces qui serait
basée sur le
le même système que les tickets
restaurant en fait
c'est un truc terre et
qu'on abonderait un compte en banque
parallèle compte en banque qu'on a tous
et qu'on abonderait que l'état
abonderait de l'équivalent de 500 euros
par mois c'est pour donner du pouvoir
d'achat alors évidemment dans cette
histoire de pouvoir d'achat il y à
l'idée de consommation ou de
surconsommation on va pousser les gens à
consommer donc c'est vraiment un
c'était vraiment une idée d'étape mais
je reviendrai pour parler de ça si tu
veux tu connais la jude la jude jude non
non on crie tout bon tu en verras non
non les crypto j'ai acheté du bitcoin
est de les taire
j'ai acheté 10 euros de bitcoin et 10
euros des terres de dire nouvelle j'en
étais à 6 j'ai tout perdu mais cet été
c'était pour voir si ça fonctionne et
les codes qu'on donne sur la jetée au
sinistre coach et vivant dit non non
mais a donné ça va pas acheter derrière
acheter un
aulas oui j'ai dû en acheter un peu et
tu t'es fait rincer away reims est
complet mais sur les stock-options était
c'était assez marrant parce que
c'était en 2000 je crois et lescure me
donne
je reçois un truc de stock options moi
je comprends pas trop ce que c'est je
lui demande il dit tu mets ça dans un
tiroir occupa dans cinq ans tu les
ressorts si l'action a monté tu les
ventes vers la de l'argent si cbc tu les
gets
d'accord et puis j'ai laissé faire ça
par contre en 2002 quand le deskur s'est
fait virer il ya il ya deux histoires
marrante d'abord c'est que les gens pour
que je puisse assister à un conseil
il fallait que j'aie 7000 ou 8000
actions et donc des gens on envoyait le
enfin pas leurs actions de leur pouvoir
sur les actions de lan procuration sur
leurs actions et je me suis retrouvé dix
mille actions mais qui n'était pas à moi
je leur ai rendu après pour pouvoir
assister à ce truc là et j'ai appris
mais six mois après que messier m'avait
donné des stock options
je ne savais pas il les avait donnés je
n'avais pas pris connaissance du
courrier qui avait qui m'avait envoyé
puisqu'ils étaient restés dans canal
c'était un truc interne donc la bêta
ouverte c'était resté presque un mois
avant qu'on me le donne et messier
m'avait donné ces stock options juste
avant que j'aille l'engueuler
publiquement dans une
truc d'actionnaires et ça a dû me me
valoir ses foudres aussi de dire s'il
est dégueulasse je donne de l'argent cet
abruti là il fait baisser l'action
fait rire dernière question internet
d'exaucer est à connaît-il et que
pense-t-il du livre petit cours
d'autodéfense intellectuelle de norman
bailar continue alors je ne vais pas lui
je n'allais pas lui est ce que tu es
trois livres une conseillé aux alors oui
un dans lequel je suis qui s'appelle
manuel indocile de sciences sociales
pour des savoirs résistant c'est
130 universitaire qui sur des sujets
amène un autre point de vue que le point
de vue dominant ça veut pas dire qu'ils
ont raison ça veut dire que il faut les
écouter aussi donc c'est un bouquin que
je conseille à tous les professeurs qui
doivent vendre le programme de
l'éducation nationale comme c'est leur
job qui le vendent mais pendant deux
heures par exemple ils font deux heures
dans l'année et puis après ils disent
lisez ça s'il ya d'autres options que
celle que je vous enseigne
qui est l'autre livre je pourrais
conseiller or un livre qui a changé ma
vie
un livre de pascal boyer qui s'appelle
et l'homme créa les dieux je sais pas
chez qui ses sorties il existe en poche
il est pas cher il faut le lire c'est un
livre sur les raisons qui font que le
cerveau humain
accepte le magic est donc accepte l'idée
de dieu et de la création magique du
monde et pour faire très court ça vient
de la paranoïa la première chose qu'on
développe que notre cerveau développe
quand l'humain enfin quand le singe
devynck aux hommes
c'est la paranoïa parce qu'il est à la
fois proies et prédateurs et que si un
signe de la nature tu arrives et que tu
réagis pas ou sur réagit pas tu peux
mourir
donc notre cerveau paranoïaque assure
interpréter des signes de là il collait
un rituel sur la mort plus
la peur de disparaître ba tu te
retrouves avec l'idée possible d'une
entité qui aurait créé tous besoin y
compris les ornithorynques qui est quand
même l'animal le plus con de la création
et en troisième livre
il leur dit heureux qu'il ait pas que
c'est débile et sert à bec de canard une
queue de castor ça pond des oeufs c'est
un mammifère il avait cours en tête dieu
quand il fait ça tiens je vais faire
chier tout le monde ils ramassent les
fonds de tiroirs ils balancent tout ça
il fait une macédoine puis on a un
ornithorynque quoi et encore on découvre
des animaux tous les jours je regarde
beaucoup planète tu as des animaux sur
les fonts main mais qui sont mes
hallucinant avec 6,6 ils sont
fluorescents pourquoi pourquoi dieu
aurait créé ça
c'est bizarre troisième bouquin ben je
cherche je cherche cherche qu est ce que
je pourrais conseiller qui a tué mon
père
j'ai lu il ya pas longtemps mais un peu
oublié son nom l'auteur je vis dans la
question internet bruno gaccio est ce
que vincent bolloré a fait arrêter lille
car cela causé du tort à sarkozy ou l
otan
il aurait bien perdu son temps s'il
avait fait ça vraiment je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas si c'est pour
faire plaisir à sarkozy mais je sais
qu'en 2015 il a voulu les arrêter et ça
c'est pas passé parce que il ya eu une
levée de boucliers y compris alain juppé
qui a mis sur son compte twitter je
crois la photo de sa marionnette à la
place de sa tête et j'ai eu par son
cabinet par des gens que je connaissais
autour de lui
le son soutien on a vu son soutien et
donc le truc s'est pas arrêtée il a
arrêté
le grand journal qui était présenté par
de caunes
et il a viré les auteurs des guignols il
voulait plus cela il voulait mettre du
sang neuf et puis
le truc c'est un peu arrêté mais c'est
ce qui se passe avec tous les services
publics tu fais dysfonctionné un truc
quand ça dysfonctionne tu dis ben voyez
ça marche pas et tout le monde dit oui
c'est vrai ça marche pas et puis on
arrête bah ouais on arrête ils sont en
train de le faire pour la sécurité
sociale les hôpitaux les universités
et nous on du rsc qu il ya un trou
qui parle du trou de la défense
nationale par exemple il ya un trou
énorme dans le budget la défense
nationale c'est le budget de l'état la
sécurité sociale ça devrait être dans le
budget de l'état un troisième bouquin
non j'étais dix et qui a tué mon père
est
oui ce livre est ce un petit livre qui
se lit vite et qui est merveilleux voilà
c'est un livre merveilleux un conseil
pour les jeunes générations je m'amusais
à sa terre leur donner des conseils bah
c'est pas
ce qu'on disait aux guignols
vous pouvez maintenant couper votre
téléviseur reprendre une activité
normale bruno gaccio merci merci à vous
[Musique]